there's no time
[Music]
the
[Music]
hey it's us it's saturday and we are
hearing it as hot as [ __ ] it's like 75
degrees in this house
air conditioner [ __ ] good wide open
75.
at least it hasn't broken this year yeah
it didn't go down this year
yeah that's good well you know i wasn't
you know i was walking down the mailbox
and looks and half these
has got two big outside units well you
can't blame them
like i said yeah yeah and it does and
even though we just had to replace like
a couple years ago but they
they just break yeah you know what i
mean because they're running so hard
yeah usually like
right around in august it'll usually go
i can't take it yeah
which i can't keep the [ __ ] house
that you see
all right just making sure you're
adjusting you're just making sure i'm in
the damn picture i was over here and
[ __ ] hold on well don't look at me
that's theirs my chair's in the same
place as it always is yours is like
movable so i don't really know
all right oracle oracle might as well i
got this [ __ ] here right in front of me
well i got this in here
you can't move it around too much
because we won't be able to hear you
yeah so i think with
we did one the other day and i think the
the microphone was turned like way
toward me so it's like i was really loud
and you were really quiet
all right for a change all right
[Laughter]
okay so yeah everything is all together
all right hi everybody it's saturday
night we've got our cocktails
see how everybody is set up we got 20 in
there right now
that's good this year yeah yeah
we're getting all the regulars we're
doing a show about howard hughes
yeah this was what was a real quick
patreon poll
yeah well i'd like i said i started
doing a poll like every week so
i looked uh if you haven't voted in the
poll for next week's show
then you have until tomorrow at noon
eastern standard time
speaking of can we hear you speak i said
if you haven't voted in the patreon poll
if you're a patron and you haven't voted
in the poll for
next week's topic in next week's movie
retrospective you have until
noon tomorrow eastern standard time to
vote on it
all right um i looked in there and it
looks like
the topic there's a clear front runner
so i i imagine there will not be an
upset
which is good because it's kind of a
good topic that i wanted to do the movie
could go
either way because there's two that are
kind of like only a vote or two apart
so we'll see how that goes yeah all
right um but yeah this uh
howard hughes in the poll this one
handily
uh and we had actually just thought
about doing this like a few weeks ago
and i think we just mentioned it on the
show when we were talking about
something else and everybody was like
yeah you should do a show at howard you
so i was like okay so i put it in the
poll
and it won easily yeah it got like three
times more votes than i did back like in
the
back in the late 90s i read a book about
howard hughes it was called
um the uh howard hughes the untold story
it was a like it was like an aw it was
like a biography of him
and it had his right hand man who helped
him run the empire
was kind of like one of the main sources
for the book and then jenny it was a
good book
and then jenny uh read a totally
different book and a lot of it crossed
over
although a lot of us and that book
didn't mention a lot of the stuff that
[ __ ] was mentioned in the one that i
read but yeah
the fascinating books really you know
he's kind of a fascinating dude
but um you know going through his life
story biographies actually you know it's
just kind of like an average story for a
real rich kid
so we're going to try to keep the movie
excuse me we're trying to keep the show
um exciting we're talking about the
weird [ __ ] that he did
yeah i mean you know talk about his life
yeah
but you know talk about like some [ __ ] i
found out that was interesting yeah
because like you said you read a
biography i read a biography that's um
that was free on kindle unlimited and i
think it was called american legends
like the life of howard hughes or
something like that and so it was free
so i read that
there's another biography there's like a
[ __ ] ton of biographies of howard hughes
like i said because he was a fascinating
person but um
the other one i checked out um another
one that was free on there
but that one i only read like the first
few pages and i was like this sounds
like a crack potty kind of one that's
like somebody that says that he
faked his own death or something like
that i don't know if that's exactly what
they were heading towards but that
seemed like it i was just like
no so i didn't read that
they had the body he died on an airplane
yeah when he was in the air
he had the body and uh by the time all
that [ __ ] happened his wealth a lot of
his wealth had been transferred over to
the [ __ ] mormon church
which that's that's a story into itself
there we need to do a whole show about
yeah
um yeah and and just the huge security
apparatus
howard hughes was single-handedly
responsible for a lot for shaping
a lot of the [ __ ] that you consider to
be modern in the modern world [ __ ] like
guided missiles
[ __ ] uh the fbi cia spy craft
[ __ ] like that oh howard hughes is
involved in a lot of that
yeah he kind of had his uh fingers and a
lot of pies yeah
what's funny and that has a double
meaning yeah
and what's funny is you know he's
building a damn intelligence
organization
a lot more powerful than the fbi at the
time
and uh he's building this thing you know
it has the ability to tap phones and
follow people and
doing complete investigations on people
it's like one of the best [ __ ]
private security
private detective agencies in the world
and he's running it to keep an eye on
girls
yeah it's some weird [ __ ] to keep in
mind he had like a lot of his
girlfriends following making sure they
weren't cheating on him
even though he he cheated on every
single girlfriend yeah he had
like he didn't even seem to like think
there was anything wrong with it you're
supposed to
yeah that was just like what you did so
but but you know the girls couldn't do
that he'd get mad
but yeah you get him he cut him off yeah
it was like the double standard type of
thing
well i think that's what made him such a
fascinating character is that
he seemed much he was a brilliant guy
was a genius really it was a mechanical
engineer like the [ __ ] that he did
but he also he wasn't actually
all that good at running businesses he
was very good at spending money
yeah um and kind of just running around
being a playboy or whatever
he didn't care he didn't really care i
think he thought that the money was just
never going to run out
which i guess it kind of didn't it
didn't for him but um so he had like a
whole apparatus of people who handled
all that [ __ ] for him because he
couldn't really be bothered he was more
like an idea guy and he did not trust
lawyers
and he did not trust people that had
college educations
he thought they were all corrupt and
that he couldn't trust him and there may
have been something to a lot of that
is howard hughes responsible for the
osmonds perhaps indirectly
yeah yeah because i think i think most
of salt lake city utah was built with
hughes money
possibly sure it looked a lot like it
dairy queen
probably had a lot to do with it and he
was kind of responsible too for making
las vegas more of like a regular tourist
destination rather than like a mafia
playground type of thing you know what i
mean yeah
um i mean it's really inconceivable
because i believe is this correct he was
america's first
billionaire that's correct right they're
not sure how much money he had they
tried to investigate him one time we're
getting ahead this is actually the show
yeah all right
but i guess this is part of the show
we're just doing kind of like an
overview
my tummy from what i read the fbi had
him under investigation they were trying
to figure out how much them
how much he owned yeah and they weren't
quite sure
he was always kind of getting into
trouble for various monopoly anti-trust
type stuff
um government contracts that he took
money for and never
uh never produced the [ __ ] that he was
supposed to produce like [ __ ] like that
yeah now a lot of that didn't have to
have to do with him personally it was
just the [ __ ] you know this is a huge
his company his empires were doing that
um
but uh they were trying to figure out
how much he actually owned
and um all of it they never really could
figure out how much he owned
now there's i guess i'm getting ahead of
myself with a story
there's one time where hughes had read
something in an aviation magazine and he
[ __ ]
got furious so he calls this big right
hand man
he's kind of like the darth vader of the
opera of the operation he's like the
emperor you know
see he calls darth vader
[Laughter]
and he goes i can't believe it they're
[ __ ] that this company is
uh making you know leaps and bounds i
can't remember what piece of technology
it was it was something aviation
because i we need to find we need to
find this company we need to crush this
company
you know he's [ __ ] ordering his men
to home in on this [ __ ] company and
just totally destroy it
all right so they're making all these
arrangements to try to [ __ ]
launch some kind of industrial warfare
against this threatening company
and months later during all this
investigation they realized that they
owned that company
that it was one of their companies and
it's because
i hope that's true yeah it evidently was
it's because
in order to like get around a bunch of
taxation and monopoly stuff and any
trust
stuff they had the empire hidden behind
walls and all these different different
firewalls so nobody probably nobody
in the structure nobody in this
structure knew everything
and they would make shell companies and
dummy companies that would own other
companies that were real
and you had to go through a damn hole
flow chart and certain
like i guess you could say branch
managers were given
instructions to make these firewalls
automatically
and it might be hidden behind three or
four different walls of
men you know what i mean or like these
little fire illegal firewalls
anyway and anyway that was one of the
things that he did
and the reason why the fbi wanted to
know what he owned because the fbi at
that time [ __ ] had heard that he was
crazy
that he had mental problems uh he did
and they were afraid that he might
do something stupid and crash the stock
market
and a legit concern right and he
evidently
evidently at times the fbi believed that
he owned
a significant portion of the u.s economy
enough to do a serious doubt he very
well may have so
hughes evidently believed they wanted
proof
that he was incompetent so they could
take him out of the [ __ ] command
structure
yeah which they probably would have done
well it was one reason
why he married later on because he was
afraid he thought that if he
married someone then the wife would be
responsible for his
like mental health you know she would be
able to take over from him and like you
know what i mean so he wouldn't be able
to get like
[ __ ] if you guys like sectioned or
whatever if you guys like
fallout there's a little expansion game
called fallout new vegas
and uh there's a character in there
called house or the house
and he's living up in a big hotel and
controlling these robots and talking to
you through computer screens
and that's directly uh modeled after
howard there are so many characters
modeled after her i mean other than like
the movies that are actually about
him like the aviator like from 2004 with
leonardo dicaprio which is a very good
movie by the way
but there were als i think like uh the
rocketeer um
tony stark from the avengers is kind of
based on him there's like tons and tons
and tons of other
fictional characters elon musk is based
on that
he's like the quintessential eccentric
billionaire yeah i was wondering though
like one of the things that the
biography that i read
said and i i think i might agree with
this
is that you know yes he had like a lot
of um
accomplishments on his in aviation in
movie production
in things that he invented and you know
various other things
um you know hollywood starlets that he
dated would like all of them at the time
um including hedy lamarr which somebody
uh somebody mentioned in the comments
yes he was friends with hedy lamarr he
was friends with
uh and dated pretty much everybody that
was anybody and he wasn't
he wasn't autistic somebody's in there
saying he might have been autistic he
wasn't autistic he was um
introverted and shy but he was real
charming i mean
um so he was kind of able to he didn't
really like to be around people but he
could schmooze you know he was socially
coptic he was yeah
like i think that although i think he
didn't enjoy it he did like spending
time with women though he was a typical
billionaire kid he grew up rich yeah his
parents were rich
and he was all homeschooled and well he
went to like really good like private
schools and he kind of had everything
no he had he had some of the best tutors
in the world come and teach him a lot of
stuff too too
i think he when he was young he went to
private schools yeah
but when after his parents died he
didn't go to university why would he do
that he would just hire a professor to
come and tutor him at his house yeah
yeah yeah
that's where he learned all his aviation
stuff he was a genius
kleenex boxes for slippers yeah he did
do that like later on yeah
the reason why he's weird you know it
didn't have anything to do with autism
had to do with multiple head injuries
that was the
that's the main one and um probably he
had ocd
um which he might have inherited from
his mom uh because she had a little bit
of that too
and he had multiple head injuries not
just head injuries he had all kind of
terrible injuries i mean he should have
died four or five times over like during
his life and all the plane
crashes he was in head injuries can
exacerbate things like ocd
yeah it would have a propensity to it
but you don't have any symptoms then you
take a couple head injuries yeah
i think he definitely did and then like
toward the end of his life he was in so
much pain that he was on
all kinds of drugs he was on morphine he
wasn't he was a drug addict codeine
uh was a coating yeah okay
well when they found it when when they
found his body he had broken needles in
his arms
yeah some of them were pretty old yeah
yeah which is
they didn't find his body he died in an
airplane they were taking him to a
hospital yeah i meant when the
authorities
getting ahead of the story he died in
the custody
custody of his security agency yeah and
um
they had been keeping him a secret for a
long time
and because he had a bunch of broke a
couple of broken needles in his arms
that had been in there for a long time
it kind of was evidence that he had been
kept unconscious for a long period of
time
by the security agency they just kept
him knocked out
um which
i'm sure at that point hughes didn't
mind
uh there's a couple photographs of him i
think towards the end of his life within
a few months i think there's one of them
and he's just unrecognizable
yeah when he died he was only like 90
pounds yeah and he was tall he was six
foot three six foot four or something
like that
no he didn't eat he had scruffy long
hair he looked like a damn bum
filthy he hadn't been bathed in years
and he hadn't like cut his finger nails
or toenails or anything like that
yeah the weird thing about him was he
was completely germ phobic but he
had a weird thing where he didn't like
have any compunctions about not washing
himself because he thought no
germs could come from him but he thought
all germs came from outside like from
other people
like so did he didn't want other people
touching him or he didn't want
anything touching him he had something
called
uh what the hell is it called alidonia
something like that um
which is kind of like hyper sensitivity
to like [ __ ] touching your skin
so a lot of times he would like sit in
his screening room like naked
because wearing clothes like hurt him
and stuff yeah now he said screening
room it was actually a private theater
and it it it could seat i think dozens
of people it was like a movie theater
pretty weird i think he stayed in the
thing for [ __ ] months at a time
he'd piss in bottles and stack them up
in the [ __ ] corners of the room yeah
and he'd have to tell he'd have just
have a telephone he'd watch movies have
him running 24 7.
watch movies he'd sleep in there and
everything he'd [ __ ] every now and
then call some girl and [ __ ] talk to
her
over the phone that was it he didn't let
people see him for you know
yeah because people wouldn't see him
they know he looked like yeah
and he he would write like these big all
these legal pads and he would write all
this [ __ ] about
and all the rules around what we were
supposed to do and a couple times he
just ran
he disappeared they didn't know where he
was we were talking about like a couple
of years
yeah and then he just showed back up
pretend like nothing ever happened they
didn't know where he was
living out the deserts businesses was he
a jar pooper
no i don't i don't think so but he was
pissing in the box
he was pissing in bottles and keeping
him i don't know
yeah where he had to be pooping
somewhere
oh i think there was a bathroom there
it's just all the drugs that he was on
uh made him constipated yeah maybe not
there's no talent but yeah so what he
would do when he was
uh in the in the theater like and he'd
be closed in there for months at a time
all he would eat was chocolate bars
yeah like chocolate bars and you have
all these [ __ ] weird stories about
hughes and and
these stories all come from his decline
you know
the second half of his life that's where
the aviator kind of ends
that movie kind of ends in a high note
but then
later he declined and that's what he
became and i was kind of sad
because as a young man he was a [ __ ]
handsome and dashing young man
yeah look i got pictures of him when i
was young check it out he was very very
well that's an older one okay yeah he's
in his 40s yeah there there you go
yeah and he broke a lot of aviation
records and race car stuff and
he liked things that had motors and went
fast he was a [ __ ] hot rodder and
real good aviation guy he could sit
there and just draw out a [ __ ]
blueprint of a [ __ ] plane or you know
basic layout of a fighter plane and he
goes
make that and he had huge aircraft
because we'll make that that'll [ __ ]
that'll be the best fighter plane ever
he had ideas about counter-rotating
props and
later on jets guided missiles you know
he was he built the spruce goose but it
didn't
it wasn't ready in time he flew it
but he broke a lot of [ __ ] records
you know long-distance flight records
and stuff
yeah and like i said he was roll up in
hollywood and stuff so
uh yeah dated all the actors made movies
he was a producer director
made a badass world war one um movie i
think it was called hell's angels hell's
angels yeah
and he did some of the flying at some of
the acrobatics in a world war one
biplane
that was one of his first really bad
wrecks because he [ __ ] crashed that
airplane in a dive
yep and he hit his head on the damn
front cockpit of the plane
and he should have been hospitalized you
know he he didn't
he took it off he shook it off he was
[ __ ] up afterwards
he just hid first some of the plane
because he was in multiple plane crashes
yeah
um i believe four at least and
i mean some of them one of the later
wrecks that he was in like it's
smooshed his heart to the other side of
his chest for christ's yeah
he was tough and it's you know it's
it's crazy to think that he like [ __ ]
lived through that [ __ ] yeah he had um
guys from mit com this is when he was
young you know in his second 20s
had him build him a [ __ ] hand-built
prototype steam turbine race car
they'd have nearly could go 200 miles an
hour and he looked at it you know it's
all those damn heating pipes everywhere
and he says if i wrecked this thing
would i get burned
by steam and they went oh yeah yeah you
would he goes
he told us he goes okay he paid for it
it was like about a million bucks
he paid for it but then he turned right
around and told this guy because i want
you to hire a team of men blow torches
and cut this thing
into [ __ ] thousands of small pieces
and nothing bigger than four inches by
four inches
and he had that car totally cut apart
because he was afraid he'd [ __ ] right
he was afraid he'd drive it
yeah because it's where he was it would
go 200.
yeah he had um he had some issues yeah
but like i
told yeah i mean what i was gonna say
before we went off on that whole tangent
was that um you know for all of his
accomplishments like in movie making and
aviation and stuff like that which were
substantial
i feel like he's mostly remembered
nowadays
for the ocd and like all the weird [ __ ]
that he did like toward the end of his
life you know what i mean
um which is kind of a shame but in some
ways
um maybe not because
i feel like people remember him you know
when maybe they wouldn't have
or they wouldn't have as much i mean if
you even people like
that even younger people nowadays if you
say howard hughes everybody's like oh
the crazy guy like that stayed in the
[ __ ] theater and like had all the
problems you know what i mean it's like
i feel like people have an idea of
of him because of that even though
that wasn't like yeah there's a lot more
to him yeah even though there was a lot
more to him than that
um so you know it's kind of a
double-edged sword i guess
while we do the um the shout out the
shout outs and the
those people send us some gifts we
should say something about yeah yeah we
should all right so
uh let's do some shout outs uh first of
all wanna
shout out our newest patron whose name
is joe
so hey welcome thank you very much also
got some presents i shouted these out on
our
uh matinee show the droving and i think
i
[ __ ] something up but uh i'll fix it
now but uh yeah so
michael sent us this right here
steel book edition special edition
friday the 13th
if you didn't see the back i gotta show
this again because i love it so much
it says killer mommy killer yeah so i
love that so much so thank you very much
michael
now these two movies i think i
mistakenly said on the droving show that
dominic had sent them but
it was actually louis sent these so
sorry about that i had a total brain
fart i had it written down every year
and everything but i still [ __ ] it up
um but yeah so this is the texas
chainsaw massacre remake which was
actually
very very good and seven
so i'm very excited about that this has
gone into the little box for the
poll for the movie stuff so we might end
up reviewing that at some point
also we have two shirts that we need to
do
melanie and victor we're gonna print
them tomorrow and either mail them
tomorrow or monday so
you guys should have them sometime next
week probably
and um as i said earlier if you are a
patron
and you want to vote in the polls what
we do
what topic we do next saturday what
movie review we do next friday then go
and vote you have until tomorrow at noon
eastern standard time
to vote on one of the topics so go do it
okay all right so you want to start
talking about howard hughes yeah
[Laughter]
all right so like i said i'm just kind
of gonna go through his life if you have
any
uh things that you remember from the
biography if i have any things i
remember from the biography we'll like
kind of bust
in along the timeline how about that
yeah sounds good does that sound okay
yeah we'll just play by ear yeah
that's what we always do with it so uh
yeah so howard hughes
uh born in texas
although they're uh they're not real
sure like
when exactly he was born as
there's like i don't know there's it's
this [ __ ] that's on his birth
certificate is different than like what
other people said about it it's like
it's not a huge uh deal
but so he was probably born somewhere in
texas 1904
now as we said his dad
was also named howard hughes senior so
when howard was a kid he was actually
known as
sunny now his dad was kind of like
one of those dudes that would kind of go
all over the country like looking for
oil
you know what i mean he was also a
gambler a
womanizer same kind of thing so that's
where howard jr got it from
but uh turns out in 1909 while he was
kind of like in with all this whole oil
drilling [ __ ]
he invented and made a prototype for
like a really badass drill bit which as
far as i know is still used in oil
drilling today
they had a problem getting through the
damn bedrock yeah yeah all right it
would [ __ ] up the drill bits
you just couldn't get down real deep so
they came up with what you would know
drill bit
today which is damn it's a shaft it ends
in three
things they're like look like
interlocking sprockets
and as you rotate it it crushes the rock
and then moves it up and it goes around
a spiral shaft to throw it out so there
isn't a sharp point
yeah i'm talking about yeah yeah it's an
interlocking three interlocking kind of
like sprockets
and it kind of crushes and churns up
rock
and then sends it upwards and uh it
doesn't it doesn't lose an edge it
doesn't need an edge
and that's what you need to get down
beneath bedrock to get to where the
really good oil is
yeah and they made that and instead of
selling it
they kept the patent and only least they
leased it so you made
millions of dollars a month by leasing
those things out
i mean his dad's company made a
ridiculous ridiculous amount of money
a ridiculous yeah to sell it would just
be stupid
yeah so well because then it'd be one
and done if you listened
to one and done and that was it yeah so
if you wanted one you had to pay monthly
and you you didn't own it they just
loaned it to you yeah
and they rode that thing until the
[ __ ] patent was up
yeah but yeah they made it they made a
[ __ ] ton of money so like his dad
that's where the fortune came from yeah
so when um
sunny like you know howard hughes jr was
a kid
like his dad pretty much struck it rich
with this company it should be noted too
that his mom aileen
uh also came from a very very wealthy
family she was like one of those
texas debutante uh type of people so her
family was wealthy as well so it's not
like he came from nothing he's
he came from like a very wealthy family
now um when he was a kid
very famously uh he had like his dad was
always off like gallivanting
like i said he was always um he was out
in hollywood because
um howard hughes's uncle rupert
was actually kind of a big deal and
holly was a script right a screenwriter
and he
you know had a big mansion out there and
like worked for mgm or yeah
one of those studios out there so um so
what would happen was rupert and howard
hughes's dad
would go out to hollywood and like go
bed all the starlets and all that other
kind of [ __ ] so again that's kind of
where
that's what dudes did back there that's
how that's where howard got that from
now his mom the thing about is i hate to
[ __ ] on people's moms for like messing
up the kids
because i feel like what happened with
the mom was that
you know she came from a wealthy family
she didn't have she didn't work
obviously because a lot of women didn't
back then especially wealthy ones
she had um you know maids and nannies
and stuff so she didn't have to like
keep house or do anything around the
house
all she had was this one kid and that
was kind of like you know her husband
wasn't around he was always off
[ __ ] around which she kind of knew
about and she was unhappy but it's like
not a lot you could do about it
so that was the culture at the time yeah
so basically all she had was this kid so
she
decided she was gonna like pour all of
her attention
into this child she needed a hobby yeah
which yeah she didn't really have that
so the thing about it was that she was
very very
i mean helicopter parent she was like
super super
overprotective and she was a little bit
i don't know if she had full-on ocd
herself
but she was real germ-phobic she was
always like worried about
she would kind of like look like check
his teeth every day and check his feet
and like check
his fingernails she'd like always make
sure that he would and she didn't really
want him to go anywhere
like she would she would only let him
ride his bike like up and down like in
front of the house like back and forth
in front of the house because she don't
want him going any place
my take of it is that she wasn't too
much fun to be around
and her husband was like happy to get
out of the house get away from her
you know he had a lot of money so he'd
go
[ __ ] chase after other women and
stuff but he'd come back he took care of
her
but i think i think i think she wasn't
[ __ ] on
really all there mentally and then him
[ __ ]
splitting like that made her mental
problems worse yeah and then i think it
kind of
i think it kind of [ __ ] gave howard
some issues that's what i think happened
it did yeah i mean i
remembered it from from the book yeah i
i definitely do think her
her being so overprotective and her
being so
germphobic disease phobic um that
definitely had an
impact on him and she was real she
didn't like him to go anyplace
so you know the author of the book that
i read
based on his sources she's kinda she was
kind of described
as being kind of annoying yeah that she
was kind of an annoying woman that
people didn't really like her all that
much
she definitely was real good looking
though yeah but she was like
hard to be around so like i said she was
kind of a society
yeah and i think i think that dad split
and made her problems
worse well yeah yeah made her her made
her personality a little bit
harder to even be around she needed a
hobby she needed a boyfriend that's what
she needed
yeah that'd made it a lot better he
wouldn't have cared i don't think
although it's hard to say because like i
said a lot of dudes like that seem to
have like a double standard it's like
they want to run around and
walk around but then it's like the
second their wife does it they're like
oh no
she could have gotten away with from
what i remember probably he wasn't
around he was never around from what
from what i remember like
like hardly ever around yeah that's kind
of the impression that i got and then
and he didn't even really uh didn't
really have a big relationship with
howard he didn't really
he didn't really give a [ __ ] yeah that's
that's how i remember it
he's and it's weird because howard
seemed to of he took after his mom in a
lot of ways but he took after his dad in
a lot of ways too
like uh the womanizing the kind of like
once you're out of his life he just cuts
you out completely and he doesn't
really think about you anymore yeah he
was single though it was different
although a lot of the
women that he was banging weren't but
yeah yeah well he wasn't always single
though he married a few times and he was
still
you know he was still he married at
least twice maybe a serial behavior for
him though
it was yeah that was everybody knew he
was a rich guy he was good looking he
was popular he was a celebrity he was
always in the newspapers you're talking
about
that like [ __ ] stark you know you're
talking about a dude that
it was a known [ __ ] billionaire and
uh
he was a very eligible bachelor and he
wore it out
oh yeah big time that [ __ ] out and he
only dated [ __ ]
hot young starlets that's what he was
into yeah
and um you gave me any any [ __ ] he just
got rid of you he replaced you with
another one so
well it's like he didn't have to replace
you because he had more he had like
three or four or five
going at the same time but you know and
they didn't always know about one
another but that's what you would do
i was in a similar situation like that
in brazil that's what you do
you do it because you can you're young
and you can
you know the thing is i don't know why
you didn't get sick of it
he never seemed to though i think it was
just normal
i mean other than you know other than
when his mental illness started taking
over he just withdrew from
everybody um it really does seem like he
just never
got tired of it yeah i don't think he
really
i don't know there's i don't know if he
actually
loved any of them i think it was just
default behavior yeah
some people have thought that he did
that there were some of them that he did
actually love because but it was hard to
tell because he would tell all of them
like the same [ __ ]
you know what i mean he blessed me he
bought them like the same
uh all the same uh engagement ring like
with the emerald on it like he bought
like 12 or 13 different ones of those
and it's like he would he would tell
like every woman the same exact thing so
it's hard to tell like if
it was just ass yeah pretty much i think
it just seemed like i think it was just
default behavior that's how he grew up
doing that
and that was just normal and that's what
his dad did so i guess he's just like oh
that's what you do
that's what you do and that's and he
could
like if you have enough money to eat at
all the restaurants why don't you eat at
all the restaurants yeah you don't need
one restaurant
that's what he's doing yeah if you have
enough money for a bunch of cars why do
you want one car
you just have a bunch of cars well
that's what one i was watching there's a
uh there's a documentary on tubie called
the passions of howard hughes
that's based on a book um that's just
kind of all about his womanizing and all
the actors and stuff and they talked to
like mimi van doren and like people that
actually knew him and dated him back in
the day
um you know jane russell and stuff and
uh one woman on there i can't remember
uh
terry moore i think it was who actually
said she married him i might get into
that a little bit later on they're not
entirely sure because there's no proof
of it
but um she said that howard was like a
little boy
in a candy store it's like he has both
of his arms
both of his hands full of candy but he
just like looks at all the other candy
yeah he's just like
he just wants all the candy that's what
i'm about that's pretty much what she
said he was like that's what i'm a man
but he got away with it because he was
super charming she said that he could
talk his way out of anything
yeah that's what she said or he could
buy his way out of anything that too
which he did he killed people and talked
about his way out of it
pretty much yeah i mean i don't think he
didn't meet he didn't mean to
but he did it it was his negligence and
like his
he was drunk driving he was drunk
driving it's okay he was howard hughes
that's what i mean see rich people can
get away with yeah they weren't going to
put him in jail
anything they weren't going to put that
dude in jail yeah
so yeah so he had kind of like a really
weird
i've seen it called a quote unquote
emotionally incestuous
relationship with his mom he apparently
allegedly
slept in bed with her until he was 10
years old which i thought was a little
strange
um when he was 10 finally he was able to
convince his mom to like send him to
this
camp it was like a boy scout camp summer
camp type of thing like for eight weeks
and um she kind of freaked freaked out
like at first she didn't like him being
away but she finally conceded
and he really liked it he liked being
like outdoors and she kind of
i think he did it a couple years in a
row now the second year i think
something bad happened and she like
wigged out and had to come pick him up
and everything because that's just the
way she was but
you know so um even when he was in
school he was
obviously really really intelligent but
he was kind of meh
about school like he was really into
science and math and [ __ ] like that but
he liked to build things he was a
tinkerer
yeah i the book that i read had more
details on them
he thought school [ __ ] sucked because
there were other students in it
which meant it meant that the program
had to go more slowly
so later on when yeah i get that later
on when he was
after he got emancipated he was just
hiring professors to come and tutor him
and he could cover years of material in
a matter of months if it was just him
and we're not talking about some kind of
menses or anything
he was i would very high iq
probably about 145 150 at least i'd say
it's just that you know school is slow
yeah yeah you got to go and you got to
[ __ ] do homework and then turn in
papers and this and that
it's a process you can speed that up if
it's just one person
yeah and a teacher worked and that's
what he's doing well because you don't
have to worry about everyone else
because sometimes like other people take
longer to get a certain
concept than others and it's like so
everyone has to kind of like be
back at that level one-on-one howard
could learn it
one-on-one with it with a professor in
just in discussions and drawing it out
and explaining he could learn it [ __ ]
quick
yeah that's how he learned aviation uh
[ __ ] aviation engineering
what do they call it i guess you could
call
aerospace engineering yeah aero
engineering
well yeah i mean when he figured out
that he wanted to learn to fly he
basically i mean he had the money then
so he just went up to a guy that
was a good pilot and he said hey i'll
give you a hundred dollars a day like
back then
yeah to teach me to fly and the guy was
like can do
right so you know and he wasn't like a
[ __ ] house
engineer i mean he knew all the theorems
and the formulas he could do all the
math
you know he was the real thing yeah he
could even draw out blueprints
yeah he did do that louis hernandez says
i think he attended caltech
i think he did as well although his aunt
has said that he just
because there's actually i don't think
there's any record of him there
but his aunt said that he had um tutors
no um that he had uh what do you call it
when you go to the class but you don't
get a grade for it
oh honorary no no no um [ __ ] what
[ __ ] what's that word what's that word
you don't get a grade for it yeah
it's like um i don't know oh [ __ ] i'll
probably think of it like if
i had it and then like it slipped away
but yeah um
i i audit there you go thank you we
audit the class yeah
his uh his aunt said that he audited
some classes at california yeah
howard did not give a [ __ ] at all about
um
diplomacy now everybody's like it's
audit yeah
howard did not give a [ __ ] about
doctorates diplomas degrees or any kind
of paper or any kind of official [ __ ]
from his point of view that's that was
for poor people that's what you needed
to get jobs
he gave people jobs you know i mean he
could buy anything he wanted
he wanted the knowledge but he didn't
need
he didn't need formal schooling to make
himself feel better about himself you
know tomorrow
he he didn't he didn't need it well yeah
i mean
what he had to do get a job he had money
david guy was a [ __ ] billionaire
so he didn't really he ended up
basically owen he
he used aerospace you know he doesn't he
doesn't need anything
that's what his employees had that's why
he looked at it
yeah so yeah so like i said when he was
a kid
um you know he had the first like
wireless radio transmitter he built like
the first motorized bicycle he was like
in the newspaper and [ __ ]
he went to like some private schools uh
in massachusetts
now when oh thank you very much dan
thank you thank you thank you
let me see some in flash clubs people
thank you very much
so now it's trying to get at least a
hundred bucks out of you people
i got bills to pick we do i have so many
bells but yeah
um so in 1922 when howard was about 16
years old
uh his mom actually went in for a
routine surgery
they put her under anesthetic and she
died
so it was yeah well it happens uh some
people
yeah or don't have a good reaction to
anesthetic that's why they are always
like kind of warning you about it yeah
um the strange thing about it is that
even though he'd been like weirdly close
to his mom
um a lot of his family members have said
he behaved very
strangely like not like not the way they
would have expected
it was almost just kind of like the next
day he's like oh well
time to like get over that you know what
i mean it's like he seemed to get over
it really quickly i don't know if he
really did or if he was just really good
at like
i don't know he was a weird dude and he
was just like good at tamping down his
emotions i'm not really sure
so yeah so he was 16 when his mom died
and then um
i think it was actually she went i think
they found out later that it was an
ectopic
pregnancy that had killed her the
anesthetic killed her i'm not really
sure one of the other two things
now uh when a few years later when
howard was
19 his dad dropped dead of a heart
attack
in his office he was just like standing
by his desk and boop he just fell on the
floor and died
now interestingly back in the 1920s this
is very weird i didn't know this
back in the 1920s you weren't considered
an adult until you were
21 i mean now it's 18 but back then it
was 21
so howard was only 19 so he wasn't
really considered an adult yet
which is very strange so he ended up
having to
basically go to court to get emancipated
like from his family
now what ended up happening his dad had
you know the hughes
like uh tool and die company or whatever
the hell it was called which was worth
like
all the money and what was supposed to
happen upon his dad's death because he
had written a will was that half of it
was supposed to go
to his wife aileen uh howard's mother
and then
like 25 of it was supposed to get a
howard and the other 25 was supposed to
go to
howard's grandparents or some other uh
relatives or something well since
uh howard's mother had was already dead
howard ended up getting 75 of the
company
and then he went and bought the other
quarter of the shares from his relatives
so he owned the whole
[ __ ] shop as soon as he got
emancipated
and like i said this was a massively
massively lucrative
company and i mean the fact that he used
that company to fund
every single thing he wanted to do like
[ __ ] hollywood
movie productions like all the aviation
[ __ ] he did everything like that i mean
this was like a money printing machine
this company
especially during wartime and stuff like
that that made like all kind of [ __ ]
money and it seemed like it was never
going to run out
yeah he eventually bought something
called rko pictures rko pictures
some of you older some of you older
people might remember that one
so black and white movies they'd have a
damn globe and on the top there'd be a
radio tower with [ __ ] beams coming
out of it and a plane flying around it
like a model
that is howard hughes and that was his
[ __ ] company logo and that's his
plane
he was breaking some kind of record that
he was famous for
yeah and yeah [ __ ] rko pitch
and he built rko pitchers to get laid he
just wanted well it's
our camo pictures were already there he
bought it he bought it but um
and he actually um he didn't do very
well like financially he kind of ran
into the ground yeah he didn't make
money
because they were making like a bunch
more movies but then he took it over and
like all this kind of [ __ ]
he kind of did it just to get girls to
get girls yeah
which is like funny to think about but
it's that's legitimately true that's why
you did it and it's kind of shitty
because and i might get it it was young
at the time though i might get into this
a little bit later but it's kind of
shitty because
uh one thing that he would do once he
had his own movie studio
was that he would find all of these
girls
um you know and he would discover them
and then he would make them sign a
contract he would give them a car he
would give them a place to live
and he would say that he's going to put
him in movies but he would never put him
in movies but he wouldn't
let them not to make movies they would
he wouldn't let them make movies for
anybody else so he pretty much
tanked their careers yeah and then he
wouldn't even date him
well because he had like there were so
many he'd forget about him yeah
because as soon as a new one came along
he'd be like oh there's another one yeah
he'd forget about him and then he'd have
his whole security agency
tailing all of them to make sure they
weren't [ __ ] around on him
yeah well they didn't even know that
they were dating him yeah
that that was how that's the way
howard's whole thing he
just wanted control he wanted to possess
everything i mean in pretty much every
he wanted
even it wasn't just women it was like
movie production ever he wanted control
of
every single yeah detail
and you know what i mean he was very
very obsessive like that i think that
was very
um a couple of the people that uh that i
saw in this documentary because i
watched a couple different documentaries
about him
but um some people that had known him
and dated him and stuff
were like um it's weird because a lot of
them like said that he did some really
deeply shitty
stuff um and that he was really ruthless
in a lot of ways but like as a person
he was actually pretty likable um and
like really charming and stuff which is
probably why he got away with a bunch of
of this [ __ ] because he was so likable
but a lot of women
said that they liked him because he
was insecure yeah do you talk about gene
harlow
a little bit yeah okay yeah we're going
to get a we're going to
talk about the boat which boat
okay they had this famous actress back
then her name was jean harlow if you
look at her
she she's not bad looking but there's
not a whole lot
to look at if you ask me i didn't think
she's all that but she had
this like this real bad girl image and
he liked her he thought she was sexy
but he didn't want to be seen with her
so
he he bought a yacht just to date gene
harlow
to get her away from [ __ ] the land so
he screwed her on the yacht
did you know about that i actually
hadn't i read
that he actually never had he never
dated gene harlow
now this book said that they did they
were secretly because there were some i
mean he dated pretty much everybody but
there were a couple
uh people that he put in movies that he
was like the start of their career like
jane russell and gene harlow and stuff
that he for some reason um kind of kept
them at arm's length
yeah for the book i read he he would
have gene harlow
taken out to the damn boat and then he
would go there and meet her on the damn
boat was big ass [ __ ] pleasure yacht
yeah and they'd spend the whole weekend
out there on the yacht
and then they'd part ways but evidently
they had something going on for a couple
years
yeah i don't like i said i don't know
i'm just saying that most of the [ __ ] i
read said that he didn't um but that's
some funny [ __ ]
that he wasn't that it might have been
somebody else you're thinking of though
too
that's some funny [ __ ] when you want to
screw this girl but you have you have to
buy a whole yacht to keep everybody from
finding out about it well he could
afford it yeah i guess he didn't really
care
yeah but yeah so uh during this time
like i said now howard had always been
into like airplanes and aviation and
[ __ ] he'd like learn to fly get a
pilot's license everything
but in the early 1920s what he was
really interested in was
movies and he was super interviews he
would just like he had his own screening
room he would sit and like watch all the
movies
there's a story that and i'm not sure
what year this happened but
that he bought uh a local television
station
just so he could tell it what movies to
show yeah
and like he would call it and say like
i'm sick of this movie put a different
one on like even it was like in the
middle of one
right they would do like [ __ ] like that
or if he had to like go to the can or
something he'd come back and call and be
like hey can you back it up like five
minutes outside
it's like [ __ ] like that i don't know if
that's true but it's like probably is
true that's another story that went
around about him that he bought a whole
tv so he just so he could like
have control over what movies that they
showed what makes sense they didn't have
vcr back then
that's i know isn't that weird it's like
it seems dumb nowadays because it's just
like
now you can just like pause [ __ ] you can
just hold whenever you want to
but yeah like back then back then you
needed a whole building so you couldn't
have it in your apartment
yeah so it was it made more sense to
just buy the the the television station
local near you
and just tell it what to play yeah yeah
that's
good thinking that's what he did very
good thinking but i just thought that
was very funny yeah
so yeah so he was super into movies so
1926
uh he moves out to hollywood now like i
said he did have
uh all the money and also he had kind of
an
inn in hollywood because his uncle was
uh very well-respected screenwriter
movie director out there so he had like
some connections uh before he went out
there
now so he goes out there and starts
making movies
uh the first couple that he made were
not real successful he
was uh he actually just started out as a
producer just like giving
money to like other directors but after
a while he was just
he would get into arguments over what
the how the movie should be done
and this that and the other so a lot of
times he's just like well i'm just gonna
direct it myself because like i said he
had to have control over everything
now so he ended up uh producing
uh two arabian nights from 1927
which actually won an academy award i
don't know that movie might be
lost uh might be one of the ones because
a lot of ones from that era are
gone are gone now uh also in 1927 he
started working on a movie called
hell's angels now this was going to be
set during world war one and howard
hughes was very concerned
he wanted this to be like the most
realistic
like flying movie like ever so he had
like these people like scouring the
countryside
finding actual planes from world war one
finding actual people that
pilots that have flown a world war one
to put in the movie like to augment like
the stunt pilots
it had german pilots from the war and
everything yeah he wanted it to be like
super
it's basically a war reenactment yeah
like because they're like
reenacting like the dog fights and stuff
because he wanted everything like
absolutely perfect
dudes got killed during the filming of
it they did i think three men got killed
during i believe it was three men got
killed during the
making of this yeah but yeah so this
movie
because he was so exacting this movie
took what [ __ ] like three years to
make or something like that because what
ended up happening with the time it was
out it was already old-fashioned well no
what ended up happening was that when
they were
a little more than halfway through it um
talkies
started to become like with the jazz
singer and all that kind of stuff
now hell's angels had first been made as
a silent movie
so he's like okay well we have to start
all over again we have to like remove i
don't think they started all over again
they kept some of the footage
but all the dialogue [ __ ] had to be
redone and everything like that now
the actress that had been in the movie
to start with uh her name was greta
nissen
now she's a beautiful woman however when
takis came along she had a real
thick norwegian accent so
that wasn't happening so that's where
gene harlow came in
now apparently howard hughes i mean gene
harlow that wasn't her real name that
was anything like
she didn't look like that like her hair
didn't look like that her nothing like
that so howard hughes pretty much took
over
the entire her entire look like what she
looked like he told her to like bleach
her hair like that he told her to dress
like that
he told her to act like that so she was
kind of like a creation of his
and so she ended up being in hell's
angels and that's kind of how she got
uh famous but yeah so even though the
movie took three years to make it went
like super super over budget as it would
um but it did come out in 1930
um and it got like pretty good reviews
like the story wasn't any great shakes
it was just kind of like a drama about
like two pilots that fall in love
in world war one blah blah but all of
the critics really loved like all the
flying [ __ ] and it's like you know that
was really impressive
so that kind of like went a long way
toward um
toward it being sort of a classic
because that's like the first time that
had been done
i think that movie was the first time
howard had a serious head injury
was making that movie uh yeah because i
think one of the dogfight things
like he did a dive himself and he didn't
pull up in time
and the the plane went right into the
ground well
wasn't it you didn't pull up in time i
think he broke a wingspar
he was in a big he was in a [ __ ]
power dive and he was supposed to pull
up in time
and he was from the book i remember
reading he was get he got into an
argument with the german
pilot the german pilot was like i'm not
going to do that man the [ __ ]
wingspar will break and [ __ ]
i was like i'll do it's trying to
[ __ ] convince him
wingspah will make it you know and and
he's like you just gotta believe
yeah i think he was trying to show him
some theory
theorems and some [ __ ] math going no
it'll take it
german pilot you know he had practical
experience
with that plane and he's like no it
won't make it
he's like and um howard says okay then
i'll do it
i'll do it and the [ __ ] pile is like
go ahead go ahead and do it you do it
and he's like
he did he did it he crashed yeah it the
wings spar
if i remember correctly the wingspan
broke at pretty low altitude he was
pulling out
it wasn't a straight down dive into the
ground
it was pulling out but he bellied in
to the ground you know with a [ __ ]
broken wing
you know and i think he hit it to
probably like about 130
you know but you know planes of wood it
crushed and took a lot of the impact but
his head
[ __ ] hit that damn metal gas tank
there is no dashboard the dashboard was
the gas tank in a world war one fighter
plane
yeah his head hit that he was wearing a
cloth [ __ ] helmet but
yeah because it was just not enough they
just had like some [ __ ] not even
helmets back then it's just like
made of like a quilt it was quite yeah
it was padded quilt
[ __ ] wrapped in leather you know
that's that was the normal helmet for
the
for the day alex rivera said i think we
can all identify with having to buy a
yacht every once in a while to get out
of a pickle who hasn't been there
right yeah yeah that was the story from
the book that i read that he bought that
yacht just so he could screw gene harlow
in secret
that may be true but like i said i read
a couple other biographies of him and
saw like a couple documentaries about it
and they didn't mention that they
actually mentioned that gene harlow was
one of the was one of the few women that
he didn't
really because she was more like a
professional relationship type of thing
although it didn't stop him sometimes
but
i think he hit everything he could that
looked good he probably did like it did
seem like
yeah he it did seem like he i think that
was just part of being around hughes
i mean pretty much every every actress
you can think of from hollywood's golden
age
he he's left with that woman i mean if
you were going to be i can't think of
any that he didn't
if you were a good-looking woman and you
were going to be around howard hughes
you're going to give it up
i think that was pretty much the rule of
the day well and he didn't the
thing about him was that he didn't
really seem to be rapey particularly
it's just that
he was at that time he wasn't married so
he was a very eligible bachelor and he
was a charming dude he was a good dancer
even ginger [ __ ] rogers said that
that she that he was one of the best
dancers she'd ever seen and ginger
rogers would know
um so you're talking about an alpha male
all the time
okay a billionaire in the [ __ ] 20s
and 30s all right who was good-looking
and who
was very intelligent he was going to get
what he wanted
women were throwing themselves at him
yeah like i said it wasn't like he had
to go looking for it
it seemed like everybody he was real
pretty much the most eligible bachelor
in hollywood so a lot of actresses were
just like they were just throwing
themselves out of pretty much and
you know anytime he was mentioned in the
he'd be mentioned in the newspapers and
in tabloids
and in magazines and on television he
was just mentioned in glowing terms you
know
[ __ ] everybody loved him yeah so
you're not talking about
some you know epstein [ __ ] you
know or [ __ ]
you know i mean one of these who's the
other guy from weinstein you're not
talking about a guy like eric weinstein
harvey harvey weinstein it's all the
same to me i don't care
you know who i'm talking about but yes
yeah he really didn't seem to
he didn't have to like bribe anybody or
anything like that he just seemed to be
really charming he did have like a few
creepy kind of things like having
girlfriend
girls followed and [ __ ] like that which
is creepy but other than that he didn't
really seem to have to resort to
anything
like that like to get women he he was
he was weird he didn't want to be made a
fool of
okay so he didn't want to be dating some
girl all right
and then she cheated on him and other
people knew that she was cheating yeah
so he didn't want to look like a sucker
right i think that was most of what it
was
with these agents keeping tabs on these
guys yeah he wanted control
of everything he wanted to make sure he
wanted to make sure
he wasn't being played and he wanted to
make sure that he wasn't dealing with
some kind of [ __ ] two-timing
agent you know somebody was just using
him for his money i think that think
that's what it was yeah based on what i
was able to collect and like i said it
really never seemed to me even though
he really seemed to enjoy spending time
with women he likes the company of women
he liked having a beautiful woman on his
arm
and according to many of his female uh
friends and a lot of the women that he
dated that
you know became friends later on like
katherine hepburn um
that he was actually like a really nice
guy
but it really didn't seem like
he doesn't come across as someone that
was like that was
capable of loving someone you know what
i mean in the way that a lot of people
are i'm not saying that he had i just
think that he was like kind of
emotionally distant
in that way but i don't think he saw a
problem with it
you know what i'm saying now around this
time
i don't remember the girls the name so
the girls involved
but he had to have this there was this
big event on top of one of these
buildings it was in one of these damn
new cirque when these circular
restaurants and everybody was going to
be there and it was kind of like
the dining room was in the center of it
and
you know excuse me the kitchen was in
the center of the top floor
the dining room went around it you know
in a circle
that way everybody could see out
and he invited some girl to go with him
to this big event
and then later on he invited another one
and uh his
his his assistant said wait a minute you
invited two girls to go to that
and he's like i think i can do that
though you know
it's like a sitcom plot yeah
[Laughter]
and he and what he did was is he had two
tables reserved on opposite sides the
kitchen was in between them so you
couldn't see it
okay and then he had telephones brought
to both tables
and he had his friend he would go to one
[ __ ] table
and party with one girl for a while and
he'd have his friend he had it all
all set on a [ __ ] timetable and his
friend would call him
so much trouble his friend would call
him on the phone
and he start talking business with
[ __ ] oh hold on i gotta go i
gotta i gotta take care i got some
important i got
it and then he'd leave and go to the
other [ __ ] side of the restaurant
and go hang out with that girl for 45
minutes or an hour or so and then the
phone would rent that phone
ring and he'd do it again oh yeah did he
start talking to his buddy
you know over the telephone and start
like they were talking business and
he tell i got to go up you got to be
right back so he was able to bounce from
one table to the next
for that entire evening now we're
playing this telephone game
now one story that i heard that was
similar to that that was
on this documentary that was on toby
that i watched earlier today
was that um he had had thanksgiving
dinner
with this one girl that he was dating
now i should note that one of the girls
he was dating it was engaged to at some
point was 15
so you know yeah that was an unusual
name what was her faith
something i can't remember i can't
remember how to pronounce her last name
but um so i don't i don't remember if it
was her but he had had thanksgiving
dinner with
with one of the girls in their family
and then he
went somewhere else to have thanksgiving
dinner with somebody else and then like
someone saw him there was like
that's like the fourth thanksgiving
dinner he's had today like we saw him
over here having thanksgiving dinner
with this person it's like where is he
putting all this [ __ ] food
because he had like five different
thanksgiving dinners with like five
different dates like on that
well evidently evidently he had kind of
a thrill-seeking streak in him
and that he would do that he would take
multiple girls on the same date in the
same location
and keep them all separate yeah
that was like a thing hunter says i'd be
much too lazy to date two guys and that
was right it's like god
one guy's enough trouble he was young
though at this time if i remember
correctly he's
when he was doing this he was still in
his 20s even when i was young
so this isn't this isn't something that
a guy in his 40s does you know
40s or 50s well some do but it's sad
yeah
is something that a guy in his 20s would
think that was real [ __ ] cool
he would think he was [ __ ] james bond
doing that [ __ ]
yeah he's like oh i got over it he got
like all this like he's got all these
little schedules like worked out
it's like it looks like a little
football kind of yeah exactly like
little arrows
x's and o's and [ __ ] all over yeah
do you want to end run around this way
for [ __ ] and not knowing that a real
player would just have them all at the
same table at the same time
but he couldn't think like that i guess
another story too was that
he was dating um i think he did he
started out dating
i can't remember which one was older
because uh joan fontaine and olivia
haviland were sisters
and um they already had a pretty uh
famously contentious
relationship but one of them
the older one i can't remember which one
was older maybe i think it was joan
fontaine she started dating howard
hughes
and then he got introduced to the
younger one olivia de havilland i might
be getting them
reversed but it's the same story anyway
um
so he started going out with the other
one and then the other one found out
about it like because
he was dating one and then he went over
to the restaurant across the street with
the other one and she came over there
and she was like ah
so there was like this big so that like
i said those two sisters were already
kind of
at each other's throats anyway and then
uh after that
they uh didn't get along so well after
that [ __ ]
but yeah so um so 1932
uh howard hughes produces scarface
uh based on the life of al capone
obviously
um and you know the the one more
recently is probably the more famous one
but the you know this
it was a remake which maybe a lot of
don't people people don't know
so this movie he makes this movie and
then he immediately runs into
a problem with uh the haze code uh
howard hawks actually directed this
howard hughes did not direct it but he
did produce it
so they run into problems with the haze
code because this movie was like super
violent because like i said
howard hughes was very into uh let's
make this as realistic as possible we
want all these gun battles and all this
kind of [ __ ] like to be realistic
so it was really violent and uh hayes
code were like no you have to cut this
out you have to so it went back and
forth for like
which is why a lot of the movies that
howard hughes worked on
um went way over budget and took like
forever to do not only because he was
super anal retentive about every single
detail
but also because he kept getting in
trouble for various things and he would
have to keep going but then he would
whatever
versions are exist well uh the the uncut
version did actually come out because he
fought against the haze code
now one thing that somebody i saw a
documentary about him and they said you
know he didn't really care
um you know ideologically about
censorship
it was just kind of like one he didn't
like being told what to do
um so if somebody said hey you can't do
that in your movie he's like [ __ ] you i
can do whatever i want
um but two he also liked to court
controversy because he knew that that
would make more people go
see the movie right um so he liked it in
that sense so he liked to make a big
stink about
how they were trying to like censor his
movie and everything
yeah so uh
yeah so in the end uh there was a lot of
back and forth it took forever but they
finally
um he finally succeeded in releasing it
either completely uncut or
you know essentially uncut even though
it was very violent it turned out being
to be like a really big hit now
another movie that he was a producer of
and this was uh several years later this
was in
1940 uh that's
probably one of his better known uh
production uh credits
is the movie the outlaw which introduced
the world
to the assets of jane russell
now jane russell was um this was
actually her first movie
uh she had just come to hollywood and
she was like discovered i believe she
was only 18 when this movie came out so
she was very uh inexperienced
uh but she comes in uh howard hughes
sees her knockers
and it's pretty much like yeah we're
gonna put her in the movie yeah you made
a bra for
uh yeah although it's very interesting
because
so she's in the movie and uh
so he's he's like shooting her from all
these different angles and everything he
wants her boobs
to look complete he was a total boob
dude by the way he was like what was
that he was like really into like
big buxom uh boob women like i said he
loved maybe bandora and all that other
kind of stuff so those big ol
titties yeah so um so he's trying to get
like the
the platonic ideal of the tit you know
what i'm saying
so he goes and he designs
so the story goes he designed a special
bra
for jane russell to best uh you know
exemplify the boobage
i think i saw it but i didn't really
understand what he was going for in the
best way possible well here's the thing
the thing about it though is that so he
designed it um
according to her because she was
interviewed in this documentary that i
saw
um she wore it for a little while but
there was like a whole bunch of metal
and [ __ ] it was like super super
uncomfortable
so she's like basically she just went in
her dressing room and like rigged up her
own [ __ ]
like with a regular bra and like
sticking some other things in there and
they just told him that it was that
and she's like she didn't think that he
would be like ballsy enough to actually
like honk and check
so she just wore that because she said
the thing that he designed was i thought
that was good enough
well yeah well he didn't know he thought
that it was the one that he had designed
but she said yeah i wasn't wearing that
because it was way too uncomfortable it
was like all
like [ __ ] metal widgets it was like
it was like cantilevers and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
she's like it was ridiculous and she's
like i wasn't wearing that it was like
super uncomfortable
so she just went in the room and like
made like her own kind of cobbled
together one that was
like similar yeah it's like you know
the thing about it it's like trying to
be rational to do it with an engineer's
mind
yeah but it's like yeah it's you can't
do that because i mean it's bad enough
even nowadays even in this enlightened
age
um it's very very hard to find a bra
that's comfortable
you know what i mean um yeah well you
don't know you don't know what i mean
women know what i mean yeah it's very
very hard to find one that's comfortable
it's like pretty much
every single one and they're expensive
they're like 50 bucks each
and then you buy one and then it's like
it never fits exactly right i don't i
don't think i've ever had a bra that fit
exactly the way it was supposed to i
don't think i've ever had a piece of
clothing ever that fit
exactly the way it was supposed to it's
very frustrating
but yeah so that was kind of like a big
and he got into trouble too
uh with the haze office on the outlaw
because pretty much the whole
because it wasn't that great of a movie
um i believe they called it the genre
was
sex western like it wasn't even really
like historically accurate or anything
it was supposed to be like about uh
billy the kid doc holliday all that kind
of stuff but it wasn't like uh
historically accurate
it was pretty much like jane russell's
boobs the movie and
they they pretty much put her in all of
the advertising
and i mean the the advertising it's
still i don't know if it's still famous
now but i mean when i was growing up i
remember seeing that [ __ ] that ad
everywhere
of her like laying in the the [ __ ]
hay bale or whatever with the gun
and then like the with the blouse like
off yeah one shoulder with like the big
titties i don't remember them being that
big though well they weren't like
freakishly big but i guess for the time
they were for the time
because they didn't i mean this was like
the 1930s 1940s they didn't really
like people didn't really get breast
implants it wasn't like yeah so that
wasn't a thing
breast implants really weren't a thing
until the 50s yeah
and and very rare even do you know where
breast implants came from
where's that japan yeah yeah it was a
japanese invention post-war japan
um they realized uh the uh
prostitution was legal there yeah and uh
the japanese girls realized that they
could get more money from a gi
but if they had big boobs that they were
so
japanese scientists figure out how to
[ __ ] make bigger boobs
ain't that some stupid yeah they were
like we can figure out how to
men we need to put our heads together
[Laughter]
these [ __ ] gotta have some bigger ass
titties okay man
and they came up with [ __ ] it first
started just with [ __ ]
um silicone injections they would just
directly inject it right into the
[ __ ] which i feel like now
people do that now just be like on the
cheapy side but that's probably not the
best thing
like they injected into glasses and
stuff i saw a bunch of [ __ ] different
things on this
everything nowadays for a long time
silicone was kind of banned in the
united states it [ __ ] the way to go
was
you had a silicone rubber
balloon basically as the implant they
filled it full of saline
okay the problem with that though is
saline doesn't weigh
what silicone gel weighs so it doesn't
quite
move it's not quite heavy enough it
doesn't have the proper flopping right
it doesn't flop as much
well in brazil they never had that
problem they just use straight silicone
all right you can put silicone into a
[ __ ] that same
implant and it gets a
you know the shape is easier to maintain
but it has a nice weight it has a
natural
movement pendulousness yes right now one
of the things that they noticed
with this is that if the if the silicone
um
implant ruptures the gel or the silicone
gel
can escape the the implant
but it doesn't it doesn't permeate
through
the scar that has formed around the
implant
so it stays in there yeah so a lot of
women
silicones silicone implants have
ruptured decades ago but the implant is
still there
okay because of the scar tissue because
the scar tissue there's no difference
between
having the silicone up against that scar
tissue
and having the implant against the scar
tissue because it's both silicone
so that goes back to the whole idea of
why the [ __ ] is there an implant why not
just inject the silicone there are some
[ __ ] doctors that still say that's
the most sensible way
but it requires a little more of an
artistic touch to get the look right
well yeah because you can't just like
stick the needle in and like squirt it
everywhere because you're going to get
like all kind of weird
[ __ ] but there was back in the early
days of just
injecting silicone directly into the
[ __ ] flesh
there were real artists that knew how to
do it
all right and to to get a real good look
and you could adjust it
you know what i mean like i said you
could come back later he goes i think
i'm gonna add a little bit more here
and you know you can do it in the ass
and everything and
the only people doing that now that i
know of really are just like brazilian
street hookers
yeah uh and they have problems every now
and then because the silicone they're
getting is like
something that is industrial grade [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's
it's not medical grade silicone so it
might have bacteria and it's been stored
in [ __ ] containers that are not that
clean
that's what i mean it's not sterile but
i saw some [ __ ] [ __ ] from doctors
that
in a big debate about that that they
should just [ __ ] go right back to the
[ __ ] silicon but i think i don't
think they'll ever do you know why
because they know people will be able to
source and if [ __ ] medical grade
silicone and do it at home
and save a lot of money mark says tom
missed his calling
i should have been a plastic surgeon you
probably should have been he's boob
obsessed yeah trevor trigger says it's
like build a boob workshop
oh my god i love it i'll tell you man
implants was like
that was like the [ __ ]
what was it what was that [ __ ]
program that we had [ __ ] to make the
atomic bomb again what was that [ __ ]
called
what was the name of that [ __ ]
program to make the atomic bomb oh
[ __ ] now i can't remember i can't
remember i'm getting drunk
yeah i guess so yeah but yeah so uh
so jane russell's boobs actually made
the outlaw a really big hit
uh apparently one of howard hughes more
famous quotes
about jane russell was there are two
good reasons why men go to see her
those are enough so basically it was all
about boobs and
like i said the the uh the [ __ ] with the
haze office and like them trying to
censor it and everything like that just
made it
more popular so it ended up making a
whole bunch of money now that was
actually
um uh the last
uh film that he was kind of really
majorly
involved in the manhattan project there
you go
i couldn't think of it either just like
i couldn't think of the [ __ ] word
audit earlier fake titties were
was the japanese manhattan project
we were building atomic bombs and they
were building implants to put little
little four foot ten japanese girls well
you know
yeah that's you gotta be good at
something give your double h
yeah this is a big world and there's a
lot of little things that could use
improvement like i said 1600 cc's both
of them okay
[Laughter]
now inflate them like a bicycle pump but
yeah so uh
as we mentioned earlier in 1948
he bought a controlling interest in rko
pictures
corporation now a few years later
um he actually sold the shares but then
the year after that in 1954 he actually
just bought the whole company again
so whatever now he actually remained
chairman of the board of rko until 1957.
and um as we mentioned pretty much the
whole entire reason that he bought rko
was to do that [ __ ] with all the
actresses yeah i mean
it seemed like he spent a
just uh a daunting amount of time
like kind of going through
you know looking at starlets looking at
women that were like one beauty pageants
that were like you know coming to
hollywood that were doing this that the
other
and he would just kind of go through and
like look at their pictures and all this
other stuff and be like yeah get that
one yeah get that one yeah get that one
so like his crew would go and get all
these women and bring them there
and like i said he would have them he
would um
he had like a weird like finishing
school thing like set up for them like
you tell them how to dress how to walk
um he would like tell him how to do
their hair he would like put him through
like all this [ __ ] rigmarole like a
camp or whatever
and he would like give them cars he
would give them a place to live
and he kept promising that he was going
to put them in movies
and he would have them sign a contract
and they weren't allowed to like go to
any other studios because they had the
whole studio thing like you had a
contract who weren't allowed to work for
any other studios when you were at
contract with
one with one student they weren't
allowed to date either yeah they weren't
allowed to basically do
anything they were almost like prisoners
stay home like in gilded cages like if
they went anywhere he'd have them
followed to make sure they weren't up to
anything
and it's like he didn't like every now
and then he would drop by and have sex
with them and it's
um weird because they were talking to in
this one documentary that was kind of
all about his
love life or whatever they were talking
to um what's his name robert wagner the
one that uh yeah with natalie wood yet
um they were talking to him and he knew
him
and he said we knew where he was keeping
all these starlets
so we used to like try to like come over
when we knew howard wasn't going to be
there
they would like go around and do all the
rounds yeah like and try to climb and he
said he almost got caught one time like
he had to [ __ ] climb out the window
and [ __ ] and then he tripped over
sprinkler head and
[ __ ] up his shoes and everything and
then howard was like chasing him
because like i said he he had like this
whole entire harem but they weren't
allowed to do anything
he had to have like control over them
like at all times
i think he meant to put him in movies
but movies never appeared
and i also think he'd forget about him
well yeah because there was always a new
one
yeah and the empire ran automatically
so he'd have one of them hooked up but a
new new ones would show up and he'd
forget about the ones that from
the year before forget all about them
yeah and
i mean even when he was still making
movies like when he kind of took over
like the
um you know the the lion's share of rko
before he bought it rko was making 30
movies a year
like after he bought it they made maybe
six
yes there weren't any movies so he
wasn't really making a lot of movies i
feel like one he had like a whole bunch
of
other interests he was just he seemed
very
scattered yeah you know what i mean like
he he seemed like he was always looking
for the next thing
and you know when he was like in the
midst of
working on something like a movie that
was going to take a long time he was
just like real exacting and everything
but then it just seemed like
when he was looking for a new thing he
was just looking all over the place and
he wasn't really like concentrating on
any one thing
it was funny you know he had a whole
empire but a lot of the [ __ ] was just
poorly managed
yeah but it still would make all kinds
of money it was weird well
yes certain businesses would fold but he
didn't care
he didn't even buy something else i mean
because like i said his
his dad's um you know oil drilling
bit company essentially um made so much
money that it must have just seemed like
he just had endless money yeah but that
eventually went away
it did i mean it went down um after a
while like he actually didn't he sold it
in the 70s like the early 70s and it was
worth like 5 billion
or something like that um but there was
a time
uh during the recession where um where
it was
he wasn't broke but he was getting there
because
he just kept spending and spending his
spending because that's what he'd done
his whole entire life
and you know really none of his um
inner circle had the balls to tell him
hey um you know the business isn't doing
so well because it's the depression and
all this other stuff and maybe you
should kind of stop doing that because
you don't have
um all the you don't have infinite money
but nobody really told him
but it kind of like all worked out it
survived though
it did yeah they would
in that book that i read they talked
about all the middle management and
managerial
[ __ ] schemes that they would do they
could
if if companies weren't making money
they'd liquidate them and then take that
and invest that into something else they
had ways of [ __ ]
keeping everything afloat and it's funny
because in general
they'd make money howard would [ __ ]
put himself spend it all
put them into debt they'd [ __ ] make
rearrangements
and then just by luck and by you know
about just some kind of weird fate
they'd end up
making more profit you know
than before the loss a lot of it was a
lot of it was dumb luck
dumb luck and good i definitely got that
that that definitely did uh come across
like when i was reading about it wasn't
any plan to most of it
yeah he just happened to always be in
the right place
in the right time yeah he didn't really
seem like a really shrewd
businessman he just seemed like somebody
that grew up with a whole bunch of money
and he wasn't he wasn't the most
emotionally mature person
um because i guess he'd been real
sheltered like as a kid
and he really never seemed to grow out
of that um
so he basically had all the money he
could do whatever he wanted you know he
was really good looking he was really
charming
he had women throwing themselves at him
and he knew that he could just
indulge his passions and like you said
he would be able to get away with
anything because he had money and he was
charming
so he wasn't really worried about
anything as the empire grew it kind of
spread out
kind of beyond his control and it went
into [ __ ] businesses that he didn't
even
really know existed yeah and the [ __ ] he
did know about sometimes would go out of
business
but the new [ __ ] in the company he even
know about that was thriving so he would
just start shifting everything to what
was making money
yeah like if you cast a wide enough net
there's gonna be fish there
yeah that's kind of what was going on
and like i said he had such a massive
like entourage and yeah you know people
working for him and then
they were good people working they were
probably making a lot of the decisions
as well you know what i mean because he
was he was notoriously kind of hard to
work for and
that's kind of a gross generalization i
mean a lot of that stuff was happening
much later we're talking about in the
60s
yeah you know where he he couldn't help
but to make money
because the empire was just so big yeah
i mean once you get a certain amount of
money it's almost like you can you can't
lose
lose it and that's eventually where he
where he ended up yeah and i think
that's what it was so it's like it
didn't really matter what he did because
eventually yeah so um
i wanted to tell the story too about
because like i said he dated
um pretty much anybody you can think of
betty davis
like [ __ ] ava gardner one story that
i read about ava gardner i didn't see
this mentioned in like
um the documentary that i watched but i
did read it in the one of the
biographies that i read
was that he was super super into ava
gardner she was kind of
um ambivalent about him she was like
yeah whatever i could take him or leave
him
which he which really seemed to like get
his gears running man it's like
he really liked you know real young
women
like young ingenues because he could um
a lot of his friends and stuff said that
because they would kind of buy his
[ __ ]
because like i said one thing that he
would do and he did this with um
with his uh 15 year old girlfriend as
well is that
you know this is back in like the 1920s
1930s when
you know everybody was having sex but
you weren't really supposed to you know
you're supposed to be married first and
all this other kind of crap because all
the morality
and that wasn't really going on but so
you still had to like maintain some like
decorum and stuff in public
so something that he would do one second
before you go any further a lot of
people don't know this
the 20s and the 30s was a sexual
revolution
here 20s in the united states i think
30s
maybe 20s and 30s in europe but
it was not a prudish time the 20s and
the 30s
it pretended to be but it wasn't
that's all i want to say a lot of people
don't know that well yeah that is i mean
they think the 60s was the sex that's
what i just said i mean i just said that
it was it wasn't like that but the
perception was you were supposed to make
it look like it was yeah
so one thing that he would do was he
would take like all these starlets and
stuff and they talked to a couple of
them
that had dated him like on this
documentary and uh he'd take him up to
like you know
make out points and like all this other
kind of [ __ ] um and he would tell them
like this one woman said she was maybe
like 17 or 18 years old she's going out
with howard hughes
and he takes her out in this car like to
this make out point or whatever
one of the drinks and yeah and he says
to her he's basically like well
she's like well you know i you know i
should wait till i get married and blah
blah like to have sex
and he says well don't you think that
only god can marry people
and she's like yeah that sounds legit or
whatever and he's like okay well
god says we're married now so he then he
tries to take her to a motel but for i
mean
to her credit she was just like no nice
try let's look let's not do that
but so that was something that he would
do a lot of the times he would
particularly if they were really young
and if they were kind of naive or
whatever
he would um you know pretty much tell
them
like you know professor's undying love
for them he's gonna marry them
he would buy them cars he would buy them
thousands of dollars for the jewelry and
clothing and he would just
buy them a house he would just buy him
all this stuff and he would say i'm
gonna marry you he would like ask the
number he would give him an engagement
ring all this other kind of [ __ ] was
basically just to get in their pants
because
once that happened he would
like take off and find the next one or
like i said it wasn't even find the next
one because he usually had three four
five six
going at the same time and a lot of them
didn't know about one another so he was
telling all these girls the same [ __ ]
but the weird thing about it um many of
the biographies that i've read
said that he you know he loved
women he loved being around these women
but the women that he seemed
to love the most the women that he
seemed thank you
to have um the most enduring
relationships with
with him were women who didn't want him
or didn't fall for his [ __ ]
or wouldn't let him get away with [ __ ]
like one of his dearest friends like him
was uh catherine hepburn now her and him
dated for a very long time
and he actually wanted to marry her she
turned him down
but they were friends until he really
like kind of went mentally off the deep
end in the end and he kind of cut
everyone off
but he really seemed to
relate to her because i mean catherine
hepburn especially
for the time uh was very um
was seen as very eccentric i mean she
wore pants
at a time when women did not wear pants
and my grandmother you say that all the
time she's like
women did not wear pants back then they
did not um and she was like very
independent she didn't really want
children she didn't seem particularly
maternal
she was very intelligent um and so she
uh you know she came across as very much
unlike
um the type of woman that howard hughes
would normally go after
but he was all about it i mean they like
i said they were friends for decades and
decades and the decades even after they
stopped dating they were still friends
and they wrote many love letters like
back and forth and stuff
but he so he really seemed to be the
most into women who
he couldn't he couldn't pull the wool
over their eyes i think she also said
that he was crazy as [ __ ] too
she probably didn't say that he's crazy
as [ __ ] you know
she was [ __ ] awesome but he really
did seem to be so
the this is a story that and i don't
know if this is true but this i read
this in uh
the biography that i read earlier in the
week now apparently he was super into
ava gardner which a lot of people were
because
she was like literally one of the most
beautiful women ever like and a lot of
people said that
so now he was after her she was like i
said she was kind of ambivalent she's
like
whatever you know we can go out she
wasn't like you know fawning over him or
anything
um so but they did eventually kind of
start going out
now the relationship was super volatile
now she was also uh hooked up with uh
frank sinatra at the time i think they
were married for a time
that was also a very volatile
relationship she seemed like a very
well they were both very volatile people
so
evidently one night uh ava gardner and
howard hughes got into a fight
i don't know what it was about and
howard hughes
even though he never had like a
reputation or anything like that about
being violent toward women or anything
like that but apparently
they got in such a bad fight that he
punched ava gardner in the face so hard
that it dislocated her jaw
at which point ava gardner allegedly
picked up a an onyx ashtray like a big
old heavy ashtray
and [ __ ] bashed his skull in with it
so
much that she said there was blood all
over the apartment it was all over the
curtains it was all over her
everything like that she thought that
she had killed him she didn't just hit
him once she kept on hitting him because
she was [ __ ] mad
now then after that so she thought he
was dead
she calls uh louis b mayer uh head of uh
mgm at the time it was that was mgm
right yeah the metro golden
golden mayor so she calls him because he
didn't call the cops in hollywood she
called like the studio head
yeah so she calls him louis v mayor
comes there sends a crew there to clean
everything up
howard's not dead they take him to the
hospital ava gardner comes to visit him
in the hospital
and howard asks her to marry him some
crazy [ __ ]
after she after she basically was right
he's crazy as [ __ ] she said now
yeah but
but he just like he for some reason that
like seemed to obsess him like women
that
didn't want him like he would like
follow them around like for a really
long time he used to get in his way
i guess yeah and i think he was
intrigued by women that wouldn't let him
have that
you know what i mean it's like he liked
it like
he liked it yeah he liked to be able to
control women like that seemed to be
like his main thing especially when he
got a little bit older he started like
going after like younger and younger
ones because like i said they would fall
for his lines
but it seemed like his most enduring
friendships or his most deeply felt
love was toward women that wouldn't put
up with this crap yeah which i thought
was very fascinating
it makes sense because he liked hard to
get
yeah he did he definitely did like he
would become obsessed if
if people said no to him so yeah so
let's talk a little bit about his
aviation
uh achievements because there are a lot
of those too
even though like you know the dating the
starlet stuff is a lot more fun
but you know so at the same time that he
was working on movies uh
starting in the 1930s um he founded the
hughes aircraft
company in culver california
now one thing that he wanted to do
he wanted to be like i said the best at
everything and he was obsessed with
aviation he was obsessed with flying
so he wanted to break
uh the land speed record uh for flying
right
so september 12th 1935 land speed air
record or the air speed rate the air
speed record yeah although they usually
have land plane
speed record is what they usually list
it as i don't know why it's called that
but yeah so 1935 um he has designed an
airplane
in order to do just that and he
succeeded
uh he broke the record uh 352.46
miles per hour which for our for
everyone else that's not in the united
states
567.23 kilometers per hour
yeah now here's here's something that's
pretty interesting about hughes
during world war ii howard hughes was
convinced when he he saw the japanese
zero
the jet which is a japanese fighter
plane he was convinced that somebody had
stolen
the plane the the the uh the plans to a
race plane that
that hughes was making as i forgot what
it was called but it was a huge howard
hughes our huge race plane
and it does look a lot like a japanese
zero he's he was convinced
that somehow the japanese had gotten a
hold of his plans
not impossible japanese zero does look
like look a lot like that race plane he
was built he was
getting ready to build i think he did
build it a couple like
like a small hand prototype but yeah
somebody in the audience might know the
name of it
yeah yeah i don't know it was just a
number it's like a huge
it was a race plane because the japanese
zero didn't look like a warplane
for the day it didn't have any armor on
it it looked like a race plane with some
jet
with some [ __ ] machine gun stuffed
and stuffed in it
that's about it yeah but yeah so
uh so yeah so he breaks that record and
then
in uh 1937 using the same airplane
uh he actually lowered the
transcontinental flight time record
seven hours and 28 minutes
so during that journey uh he averaged
332 miles per hour
he also circumnavigated the earth
in a lockheed 14 in 91 hours and 14
minutes which was also
a world record fourth drone fourth
drawer down said it was the h1
i think you're right i think it was
called the h1
he had another one that looked kind of
like a lightning it was a dual fuselage
airplane with a center with a with a
center and a cell that you sat
in with with um the props had
counter rotating props in it he wrecked
that one somewhere over there in
hollywood yeah yeah it was going to be a
real fast airplane
counter rotating props would have helped
okay go ahead
but yeah so also uh in 1939
uh he bought 78 of stock in transworld
airlines better known as twa
now when world war ii came along howard
hughes decides he's going to
turn toward developing military aircraft
so he got a couple of government
contracts to build planes for the war
effort now one of these was the hughes
xf-11
and the other was the h4 hercules better
known nowadays as the spruce goose
which we'll get into what's called that
later on now
he got into actually a lot of trouble
over these uh government contracts
because
he got um he did use some of his own
money like developing the aircrafts but
he also got like several million dollars
from the government
and as it turned out he didn't uh
actually
finish the planes that he was supposed
to finish until two years after the war
was over
yeah so nobody needed them you gotta
forgive him for all that though
he well he it's weird because he didn't
get intro i saw like some uh
archival footage of him at like the um
the hearings like about this [ __ ] and
it's even though he
was technically in the wrong um he ended
up coming out
smelling like roses where like the
senator that was kind of like
accusing him ended up like kind of
losing his career afterwards
just because he was so i think he was
trying to deliver the planes
i think he was trying to deliver the
best planes he possibly could but
because
because howard was so ocd
every little [ __ ] thing had to be
perfect on the goddamn plane and that's
not the way world war ii was you can't
yeah you just world war ii
is you mass production you get that
[ __ ] on the battlefield as fast as you
can
and hughes wasn't that kind of guy he
couldn't do that
so but he was trying uh yeah he just had
a real
issue because it was the same thing with
his movies it's like that's why a lot of
his movies took so
[ __ ] long because every little aspect
had to be [ __ ] perfect and and that's
just not the way technology moves ahead
i mean he fought like during those days
during his movie production career it's
like he started out as a movie producer
like i said which is just like the money
guy
and it would be a different director and
he would be up the director's ass
so much that directors would just quit
because they were always like fighting
they're like look just do it your
goddamn self if you're just going to be
like
up my ass about every single little
detail here you have
hughes trying to perfect propeller
driven planes
all right in an era of the last few
years of that damn war
germans were already dealing with jets
yeah
you know what i mean there was no time
to perfect propeller-driven planes
all right that that time had passed you
know
if you wanted to perfect something
perfect the [ __ ] jet at that point
but
yeah that's just not the way hughes was
yeah hughes was [ __ ] the micro
manager
but i did i did think he was trying to
get the planes out on time
he just didn't want him he didn't want
to deliver something well he said so in
that senate hearing i heard it
the recordings of it he said he couldn't
live with himself if he handed an
inferior product over to [ __ ]
an american airman and then he died
because of oversights
yeah during the development that's not
the way that world war ii was fought
though yeah world war ii everything just
had to be good enough it's good enough
and
lots of it and [ __ ] push it out as
fast as you can
it was all disposable men and material
really
it's the way it was well i mean that's
the way they thought of it
yeah so it's like the fact like i can
appreciate
um being a perfectionist but in that
situation
when the government has given you
millions and millions of dollars hey we
need x amount of planes by
this date you can't sit there and obsess
over every single detail
meanwhile you know like hey you know we
gave you all this money where is our
stuff
with a fraction of that amount of money
and a fraction of those men
and a fraction of that material just in
a mere
[ __ ] nine months the germans were
able to make a wooden jet
yeah the volks jogger okay
a wooden jet yeah that was damn near to
look like something out of the damn
1960s technology
so just the thinking his thinking wasn't
right for wartime
he'd be a good [ __ ] guy to have
like on a nasa project where you got one
shot to get to mars and that shit's got
to be
and everything has to be completely
right he's good for that
but not for war not for war production
yeah not in those days
yeah so he didn't even end up flying at
the xf-11 which was supposed to be a
reconnaissance plane yeah that was that
he flew the prototype
in 1946 which was a year after world war
ii ended yeah and the first time that he
flew it
he it crashed yeah that's what i was
telling you about to the con that was
the one that almost killed him yeah had
counter rotating props
and um that was a badass it looked like
a lightning you know yeah
the two fuselages you know in the center
in the cell look it look like that
but like i said you're in the age of the
jet already yeah
yeah that was already on its way out
yeah propellers were [ __ ] that was
it's just kind of like what he ran
into with like the hells angels movie
where it's just like he made half the
movie and then silent movies were on
their way out and he's like oh well [ __ ]
now we have to stop and like redo the
whole [ __ ]
thing that turned out successful luckily
even though it took three years to make
but yeah so
um so yeah so he flies the um the xf-11
he gets it somebody's saying was it
alex yes the volks jagger was a wooden
jet made out of [ __ ] plywood glued
together where the damn jet engine
the jet engine on the [ __ ] roof of it
is called
we call it the the hunchback but look at
the volks jagger
i think it was the me 163 i think was
with the name of it
the people's fighter it was a cheap
basically almost
near disposable plywood jet
and it flew and it was a pretty good
flyer
but by the time it was ready i mean they
were putting hitler youth in there
14 year old boys trying to get them to
fly it
yeah that's true they sent out one
[ __ ] flight wing they never heard
from it and it was mostly 14 or 15 or
boy they don't know what happened to
that wing
they sent that out after the [ __ ]
american air force nobody knows what
happened with them
i don't they didn't make it they didn't
make it back yeah i don't even think
they made it to the bomber streams if
you ask me well they probably just
crashed in the ocean and got eaten by
sharks
well there wasn't an ocean there that's
landlocked but
they they [ __ ]
the volkswagen was very interesting
[ __ ] german aviation was a thing of
desperation but they were
no money and very good brains and very
good thinking
uh they were pulling [ __ ] out of the ass
literally
trying to make a damn jet fighters out
of [ __ ] plywood
just in a few in the few final months of
the war
that's [ __ ] willpower they were smart
but
just couldn't do it you know that that
jet required an
experienced jet pilot not an experienced
airplane pilot
an experienced jet pilot to get that
[ __ ] done
and they were putting boys in there that
maybe probably could barely handle a
glider
so no it wasn't gonna happen
that thing was acrobatic as [ __ ] and
very very touchy
yeah yeah so yeah so he flies uh the
xf-11 and is a very very bad accident
which almost kills him
he he has this thing where because like
i said he was in several i believe it
was at least four
uh plane crashes like in his life that
he survived
um even though he was uh horribly
injured in
many of them this one was a really bad
one and almost killed him
one thing that he would do is that he
would be all [ __ ] up
in these [ __ ] plane crashes right
like in one plane crashes like he busted
his skull like it threw his [ __ ]
heart to the other side of his chest
like it punctured his lung like all this
other kind of [ __ ]
but he would you know people would
obviously like have to get him out of
the plane
but he would tell his crew later tell
them that i walked out of the plane like
on his own
he wanted it look like he had crawled
out of the wreckage like himself even if
that wasn't true
like he was very very concerned about
optics like what i guess like what he
looked like
so he would always tell them like tell
them i crawled out of the plane on my
own even if he didn't
because like i said this this wreck in
particular was a really bad one
so the other plane the h4 hercules
better known as this bruce goose now the
reason it's called the spruce goose that
was uh he hated that name by the way
that was kind of um a an insulting name
given
to because it was partially oh it wasn't
completely made of wood but it was
partially made of wood
although it wasn't uh made of spruce it
was actually made of birch i believe
um i think it was just the frame like i
think it had metal on the outside did it
not
but i think just the frame was made of
wood but it was this big giant plate was
supposed to be essentially
a flying boat yeah it was supposed to
hold like 750
people especially a big giant [ __ ]
plane huge seaplane
yeah it's massive and um the thinking
was good though
yeah it wasn't dumb it wasn't like a
dumb thing to do
it was going to be something you used
like on d-day you loaded a whole bunch
of troops up on the thing
and the senate senate instead of sending
them to germany and
and day-day in boats you did it in
planes
yeah which is that would have worked
yeah it's just that that's a lot of
aircraft
it just didn't yeah it had eight engines
yeah it was like a [ __ ] massive thing
and like i said it was partially
constructed it wasn't entirely of wood
but it was partially of wood
and um some said people said people said
it was too heavy to fly because it
wasn't done till 1947
and the fact that it wasn't done until
1947 that was the same year that he
uh that howard hughes got brought before
a senate committee because he was
talking about war profiteering he's like
look we gave you all this money and you
didn't produce anything like and now the
war's over
so like there was this big back and
forth between him and senator owen
brewster
um even though hughes actually dude came
out of the victor of all that
and just to prove that it would fly
because a lot of people said that it
wouldn't
um in 1947 he flew
the spruce goose one mile yeah like
about 70 feet above the water
and then landed it and it never flew
again
some more modern analysis of that thing
in terms of power to weight
and you know what i mean it's um it's
lift capabilities
uh this was you know probably 10-15
years ago now
they did an analysis and it turned out
that that thing would have flown very
well
yeah yeah they said it wouldn't fly
but no computer analysis i think people
like said it would know it would have
flown very well right because no one had
seen it fly and it was so
big and it was just like you know it
seemed like this big like um
debacle because it had taken so long to
make and it's like it was just this big
[ __ ]
thing and um it was only big for the
time
yeah it was smaller than a 747 yeah i
mean
nowadays it doesn't seem big now because
like we have [ __ ] big giant
yeah it was wood but plywood and stuff
is a
similar strength to aluminum and
i saw a new a newer analysis of it and
they said it would have flown very well
yeah yeah so it was it wasn't a hoax
it was it was you know what i mean yeah
well like that did a good job
yeah i mean it did fly like i said they
they weren't concerned about whether it
flew or not they were just concerned
that they had given him all this money
to do it and
he didn't come up with it in time yeah
it was that typical hughes
[ __ ] overthinking things and [ __ ]
he kept his he kept his ass in a knot
constantly
worrying about [ __ ] little things and
trying to perfect little things that
should be
should have been perfected later in the
field you put it out the field and then
you find a problem then you then you
you issue an upgrade kit you get the
[ __ ] out there
working that's how you do it like that's
not the hughes couldn't think that way
well i get it like he did he had mental
issues yeah he had he had mental
problems um but i understand
um you know the whole thing about
perfectionism
and it's like you have this weird thing
where you know everything has to be just
right
before you can let anybody else see it
yeah
and i feel like that was a problem for
him yeah like in some time like
you know if you're writing a novel or
something like that that might be fine
but making airplanes for the government
that they kind of need
like right now please and thank you um
yeah that's not gonna fly
so much and a lot of the [ __ ] he was
working on were such
minor details you know i mean the
airplane could have been in production
right years years ago you know well
that's why they were mad yeah that's why
they brought him in front of the
community he could have been made more
money but it wasn't profiteering
it was ocd yeah he wasn't doing it on
purpose
like to be like to make extra money out
of the government for doing this and
i'm gonna like [ __ ] [ __ ] them over
you'd have made more money had he put it
out and put it into production
yeah they would have bought it like i
said i think that in some ways he's
lucky that he was already rich because
his money just kind of like
made itself and he didn't really have so
it didn't matter
you know if he made dumb decisions or if
he like did
crazy [ __ ] because the money just was
happening like without his input almost
yeah you know what i mean
so yeah so the spruce goose did fly um
louie asked if you
ever saw the spruce goose when it was at
long beach no it was in a damn dome
it was in a dome right next to [ __ ]
uh queen the queen mary
so i never saw it i saw the queen mary
though
yeah and i saw the dome that it was in
you don't know what he's talking about
dude yeah okay yeah i know yeah i know
what you're talking about
spruce goose was right next to it
covered in a damn dome yeah i know
i remember seeing it like i saw it on i
didn't see it in person obviously but i
saw it like on the news or something i
remember my dad talking about it
we drive by it that's that damn bruce
goose this is my dad in his 30s he
didn't sound like
he didn't sound like he didn't sound
like the turkey neck damn bruce spruce
goose
it flies it might fly howard hughes he's
crazy
crazy [ __ ] poor howard hughes that's
like all he's remembered for
yeah it flew crazy yeah it flew that's
how my dad's talking hey flew it flew
it did it flew for a mile yeah he flew
it for a mile just to show that it would
got that damn spruce goose
[Laughter]
even though like i said it was made of
birch but not bruised but whatever
that's what everybody called it bruce
goose just sounds better yeah it made
him so mad
yeah he was he did not like that
nickname at all it was a term of
endearment though they weren't talking
bad about it i don't know
everything everybody liked it it was a
plane
it flew it flew
your dad
it was a big plane yeah
so all right so all this time now
he seemed to have been able to keep his
[ __ ] together
throughout the 1940s even though
um people in his inner circle people
that work for him and stuff they said
they had started to notice
little things about um how he might
not have been completely uh
mentally there you know what i'm saying
like but nothing
super alarming like not yet
um but in 1950
it seems that he decided um that he was
going to just go
into complete seclusion and see as few
people
as possible now
um during this time he also established
the howard hughes
medical institute which as far as i know
is still around yeah and yeah
it's always made money evidently somehow
they will send i don't know if they'll
still do this but a few years ago
um i got like a bunch of free
like dvds like documentaries and stuff
like about genetics and biology and
stuff like that apparently they'll just
send you
dvds for free if you want to learn stuff
wow i don't know if they'll still do it
now but
i got a bunch of stuff from there i
don't know i don't know how i came
across
it but i was just like oh a bunch of
documentaries about genetics and stuff
like gimme and i was like i still have
them someplace
but yeah so um so yeah he established
that
um using profits from the hughes
aircraft company he wanted to explore
what he called the genesis of life
itself so it was kind of like a medical
research biological research
type of institute like i said it's still
around nowadays so
that was like his you know philanthropic
type of uh thing that he was doing how
long have you been streaming what
uh almost two hours why okay you want
why do you want to do a commercial you
gotta yeah
do you need to do a commercial um i
don't i'm all right but you know what i
mean
it doesn't matter normally we do like a
[ __ ] halfway point but i don't know
well i don't even know what the halfway
point is because i don't know
like how long it's gonna be this could
be a four hour show i don't know
okay maybe not all right we've covered a
lot of stuff
already like more than i thought we
would okay
no but i don't ask for breaks i'll just
get up and go when i get when i gotta go
i'll just [ __ ] go
well yeah but then you but if you tell
me because i have like a very cute
pookie video
i have like a couple of commercials okay
yeah play the commercials then are you
sure
yeah because i'm going to say you can go
to the restaurant all right so we're
going to play some commercials and
you're two hours into it okay
i said just tell me you making me run
the show make me engineer this [ __ ]
no i just wanted no i just wanted to be
okay with you
apartment right here she's still
sleeping yeah oh my goodness she's been
sleeping this whole show
i can't believe it all right so we're
gonna play a couple commercials and a
pookie video
and we'll be back in just a couple of
minutes
join us september 25th 26th and 27th for
a three-day special streaming event
strange realities to push the limits of
your
reality featuring authors academics
researchers occultists experiencers
podcasters and practitioners
[Music]
all presenting fresh cutting-edge
material and research
streaming live featuring presentations
by brent ray
editor of alternate perceptions magazine
aaron gulius host of the saucer live
podcast david metcalf fighter
and researcher alan greenfielder of
secret cipher of the euphemism
stephanie quick item and blogger red
pill junkie 14
researcher and explorer tim bernal host
of banal of america guy malone
class and troublemaker timothy ritter
host of strange familiars
dombrowski author and practitioner greg
bishop author of
project beta juni ashford host of 13
o'clock
recluse toast of the farm jack
montgomery health magic joshua kutchen
author of thieves in the night
reverend michael carter alien contact
experiencer dr future host of feature
tony kale author of memphis hoodoo rin
collier
cultist soraya ascot host of where did
the world go
all three dates only 20 tickets and info
available at strange
realitiesconference.com
brought to you by the conspiranormal
podcast conspiranormal.com
[Music]
you love true crime i love true crime
and i've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century
it's called the faceless villain and
volume 3 is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
ketty murders the carrie babies case
the frog boys the alcasar murders and
the anoka shira park dismemberment
incident
the faithless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com
and get ready for a chilling journey
through modern crime history
so i came in tom's playing a video game
and look at pookie it's ridiculous
hey what's up sweetie she's like don't
touch my face
yeah she doesn't like when you touch a
piece hey
why are you silky she's like why are you
feeling me
i'm just laying down like a poopy dust
[Laughter]
i'm gonna put it in a cabinet yeah make
a dude [ __ ] cabinet
what are you talking about construction
store you like dune too you like when
daddy's on the floor
yeah i get on the floor and then she
wants to complete yeah she wants to come
rub on the computer she's like oh
well it's not fun anymore because i'm
sorry poke
yeah yeah okay i know i love you
that pokemon makes me laugh i recorded
that yesterday
because i just walked in the bedroom to
tell you something and you were sitting
there playing she's just laying there
going
hey what's up yeah she chills out and
i'm working she chills out
she's very very funny when you're
working playing dune
oh that see in the um the strange
realities commercial in there that
reminded me i have my time slot
i'm gonna be giving a presentation on
the strange realities uh
con uh on september 25th which is a
friday
at 10 40 p.m eastern standard time so
that is my time
slot so if anybody wants to go buy
tickets and see me talk about some true
crime [ __ ]
then i just go ahead what is that
i was going to show them the volks
jogger the wooden jet
oh hold on let me see it i can't see it
trying to get a better picture of it
i can't see it keep talking
because then you'll just like interrupt
me it was the 162 volkswagen also known
as the salamander
the salomon i thought you were going to
say something else the salad fingers
all right
there you go the hunchback that's a
good-looking plane
especially for the time yeah i don't
know if i'd want to fly in something
with that thing on it i don't i don't
like flying in planes anyway they put
the
they put the the jet in that position
outside
okay they put the jet in that position
to make the jet easily removable
because they had to be rebuilt regularly
you had to rebuild the [ __ ] turbines
yeah assembly regularly so they wanted
to [ __ ] keep a bunch of them
ready in the shop and when your jet
engine got to
old they could just swap them out
rebuild the old one
because it would it could quick detach
from the g from the
aircraft yeah i'm talking about yeah you
can swap an engine in a few minutes
that sounds sounds legit yeah so
yeah so like i said uh howard starts
going into seclusion in 1950
and uh over the following 10 years he
pretty much
um wouldn't really talk to anybody every
now and then he'd talk to somebody on
the phone but he basically like
conducted all his business through
his uh inner circle like he had like
yellow legal pads he would write all
these like rules and notes and
everything
now interestingly uh like and like i
said i'm not sure how true this is
because there's
a whole bunch of different biographies
of howard hughes out there and there's a
whole bunch of like legendary stories
because
when he would go off into seclusion
um you know sometimes some of that is
like kind of like lost time like a lot
of people didn't see him or so
nobody knows exactly what was going on
around that time
but the biography that i read speculated
that the reason that he might have
suddenly sort of gone off into this
germphobic
ocd kind of um hell of his own making i
guess
was because right around that time he
was diagnosed with
syphilis not like the bad syphilis
that'll like make you crazy
so that it wasn't that it wasn't
syphilis making him crazy
um it was second stage syphilis which
actually could be treated with
penicillin at that point
but he had a weird thing where he didn't
really want to take penicillin he wanted
to take like the older treatment for
for uh syphilis which was some kind of
with silver thing that was like had all
kinds of like terrible side effects
but he for some reason didn't trust
penicillin maybe because it was new i
don't know i thought it was a mercury
no it was silver or something it was
silver something actually
it was now wasn't that that was what
they used to make film stock out of
it was i can't remember what the word
was but um so that
so the authors of this biography
speculated that the fact that he got
a syphilis you know a syphilis diagnosis
around this time even though he was
treated um might have been like a
catalyst
that made him because after that he got
really obsessed with
cleanliness and germs and he didn't want
anybody touching him
and he didn't want he always had like a
little bit of that but now it went to
like
extremes like he would go into a room
and be in there for like four months
naked like eating nothing
he would just like slip notes under the
door it's like he wouldn't let anybody
in there
it's like if people had to come in there
to like bring him things
they had to like cover their hands in
kleenex you know what i mean
like he had all these like [ __ ] rules
it's like if he ate
because he always would eat like out of
cans like peaches and stuff
and he had all these rules he's like you
have to take the can you have to take
the label off you have to like scrub
the can like all over you have to like
then you have to scrub your hands and
you have to put kleenex
and gloves and [ __ ] like that in your
hands and then you have to pour it in
the thing in the bowl and then the bowl
has to be scrubbed
and he had like this big long like nut
everything was like a contagion
yeah later on he was that way with uh
swanson tv dinners
he had to have a certain way that tv
dinners were prepared and eventually
only tv dinners
it's because he was convinced that tv
dinners were not touched by human hands
they probably weren't and i think they
might have slightly been
irradiated yeah which might have made
sense in the 50s so he might have known
i think i remember think i remember him
saying that but you know what's weird
though
is that true or not is that he was
actually more afraid of radiation than
he was
of germs because he evidently knew about
a radiation though yeah
because you can use radiation to destroy
bacteria
inside of a sealed container because i
you think he knew about it based on what
i remember he had all that money and he
was just like eating like shitty food
out of cans and
tv dinners according to the book that i
read he thought tv dinners were the
[ __ ]
the cat's ass that they were not
touching
pajamas they were not touched by human
hands they were totally sterile
yeah they were safe to eat uh
he was that was astronaut food as far as
he was concerned you know what i mean
that was like and that was that was the
height of it
high technology [ __ ] i remember i don't
know why i just remember this i had a i
had a very vivid memory just now with
being in elementary school
and uh in the early 80s it was
like the space shuttle was like a really
big thing right because like that was
when
you know all the space shuttle [ __ ] was
starting it was like oh it's the future
blah blah blah
so we actually i don't remember what
grade i was in maybe
fifth grade i think and we had like some
actual
i think like some actual astronauts or
it or an astronaut
came to our class like to give a talk
and he was talking about the space
shuttle and everything
and then we actually got he brought like
packets of like the astronaut food so we
all got to eat some of that and it was
horrible you're telling me sheer
terrorist is streaming a live show right
now i don't need to see that i got his
girlfriend
i got his girlfriend uh yeah
somebody else is saying he didn't like
his meat touching the peas and that yeah
yeah he was real weird like that from
what i remember yeah there was a lot of
that kind of stuff he didn't like any
kinds of cross-contamination between
food groups
i've known some people like that it's
it's a weird ocd thing like they don't
like
their now i'm okay now when i was a kid
it used to gross me out like when well
you know cafeteria food
in regular like public schools is pretty
gross to start with
but there used to be like all these boys
and they would get
the the trays of the food and then they
would just like mix all the [ __ ]
together
just to gross everyone out and that like
made me wonder they poured chocolate
milk on
yeah and then that made me like want to
[ __ ] vomit i had to like move to
another table like
really really bothered me yeah um it
doesn't bother me as much nowadays
but it used to really bother me and peas
used to bother the [ __ ] out of me like i
couldn't it was funny smell them
you know our our generation we grew up
during the time of [ __ ] the tv dinner
even though that was really something of
my dad's generation it was still around
when we were kids
these people go in there get like i ate
many of them yeah you go and get like a
hungry man dinner for like a dollar
fifty
yeah and eat like two of them well i
never eat two of them i can eat two of
them
well of course you're a dude i could eat
two of them there really wasn't that
much in them
yeah they're kind of small actually it
was that big but it wasn't very tall
well yeah most of it was all right
separated out it was all tray it wasn't
much
you didn't get full off of it you just
kind of got a little bit satisfied
but you know for the time and for what
you spent
it was a good deal because for a dollar
fifty that's like
that's only a little bit more than a
mcdonald hamburger yeah
and you got a turkey dinner with the
[ __ ]
with the [ __ ] cherry [ __ ] pie and
everything right
well it was a cherry cherry pie
it was neither thing it was it was it
was a simulation
yeah it's like astronaut food it was a
cherry pie adjacent product
tv dinner you ate that [ __ ] on a tv tray
why why you were watching dinner
yeah while you were watching dinner
[Laughter]
eat this [ __ ] i'm drunk why are you
watching sanford and while you were
watching
or whatever calling him a big dummy
[Laughter]
coming to join you elizabeth it was
another time you know do you know
what i and i probably i don't know i
don't know if i'd want to eat one
nowadays
it's not exactly a tv dinner but it came
in a tray and it was like
thin perfectly round turkey slices
or turkey like with bunny rabbit ears as
uh eddie izzard says and it was like a
bunch of those
and gravy and it just came in one big
tray
and then you like stuck it in the oven
for however long it was already cooked
you just had to heat it up
and my grandma would make that and then
mashed potatoes on the side and maybe
some cornbread
i was into that when i was a kid like
this [ __ ] turkey
those round turkey slices with gravy on
them
i don't remember that so he's talking
about the damn
hamburgers that they had at school with
the soybean patty this [ __ ] was like
springy
springy [ __ ] meat i always brought
you from home i did not
i did not buy cafeteria food ever she
was terrible
i don't even think i don't i don't
remember ever buying cafeteria food
um in elementary school and junior high
every now and then like if i had you
know some money i'd buy like ice cream
sandwich or something
but i always brought food i i always
brought a sandwich
and you know like a cup of yogurt or
something high school
we could leave for lunch so i usually
high school so i either went to
mcdonald's or i didn't eat
or i went to eckerd's and got like a
pack of crackers
in middle school i was in california and
it was a public school and that's where
they had the springy [ __ ] burgers and
[ __ ] where they were
people pouring [ __ ] chocolate milk in
the tray and [ __ ]
that's so good but then i went to me
that would probably still make me throw
up and i went to military academy the
[ __ ] food there was [ __ ] great
it must have been nice it was family
style you sat at the [ __ ] table and
they came and they brought all the
[ __ ] bowls
big bowls of spaghetti and meat sauce
and [ __ ] because other countries know
how to [ __ ] eat we just kind of like
no that wasn't that was in san goes
sigma hill california oh okay
and then when i went to brazil that was
a private school so i had brazilian food
yeah it's funny because all the little
japanese girls they wouldn't eat that
[ __ ] they brought their little bento
boxes and [ __ ] with all their little
[ __ ] sushis and [ __ ]
well okay they would bring that and
they'd eat that and we'd laugh at them a
little bit
you know oh my god just like everybody
laughing at molly ringwald in the
breakfast club because she brought
sushi to the exactly well they would
have some beautiful [ __ ] brazilian
nice raw fish and seaweed
[Laughter]
they'd have some like some brazilian
won't accept a guy's tongue in your
mouth but you'll eat that
they'd have some like some brazil some
[ __ ] beautiful brazilian
food you know fizzy water [ __ ]
chicken melons or some
something like that you know what i mean
and they'd turn their nose up at it and
eat some [ __ ] cold fish and [ __ ] we'd
be like
but you know what it's way it's what you
grow up with it's not weird to them
well we you know they used to [ __ ] we
were [ __ ] around one time you know
and they were sharing it
and letting us taste taste it and i
didn't think it was bad
what they were eating it was just the
regular sushi that we didn't get at the
[ __ ] uh
she's pretty good like you get to
chinese not a huge fan but i'll eat it
not real flavorful you know what i mean
compared to what brazilian
brazilians were eating but you know
whatever they were scared though they
were scared of foreign food
they had to have it the japanese way
and those those girls were [ __ ] funny
because they their parents would dress
them like they dressed
so they all looked like bobby sockers
from the [ __ ] 50s and the 60s
that's what they they dressed their kids
like they dressed all right
they wouldn't allow the girls to grease
or something they wouldn't allow them to
wear makeup
use perfume or shave their legs so they
had [ __ ] hairy legs and [ __ ] no
makeup and they're going to school high
school
around brazilian bombshells
from the [ __ ]
this is the brazilian upper class they
were just genetically selected for
hotness
you cannot marry into that class unless
you're hot by brazilian standards which
means
booty just booty and beautiful
[ __ ] legs oh yeah they're just all
they were they are a
lower body ethnic group it's all just
about from the waist
down they're
kind of flat and the dudes they're big
into soccer they don't have any upper
body strength
you know i mean they're always [ __ ]
lower body [ __ ]
they're they're in in that era they were
about
lower body strength they weren't into
that american football or [ __ ]
working out you know what i mean
they just they were just into running
around on the [ __ ] soccer
field yeah that doesn't have a lot of
endurance for them
but there's just the i feel sorry for
them poor little those poor girls
well yeah i mean that's that kind of
imagine your parents not letting you
not letting you yeah i mean if it was me
i i would just take makeup with me in my
bag and put it on when i got
there there were no japanese boys they
were all back in japan
because they mattered yeah the girls you
have [ __ ] off yeah yeah
no they have to go back to they have to
stay in japan
in an expensive school because their
futures matter so they need the best of
education but the girls will keep with
us we'll just send them to one of these
little
foreign schools where we have to work
you know yeah we'll send them off to
some other country so we'll have to look
at them well no they were going to
another country their dads were working
in brazil
but the suns all stayed in japan yeah
because their
education was too expensive to sacrifice
on an international school
yeah they'd never make it in in japanese
society
it was a weird [ __ ] time i don't know
if it's that strict nowadays
but back then it was but those girls
i don't know how i got on this subject i
don't know either i don't know but those
girls were like middle schoolers
those girls it was funny because that
particular school
the japanese girls looked and acted like
middle schoolers in a certain way
and the [ __ ] brazilian high school
girls
acted like porn stars so you can imagine
like which girls the dudes were gonna
actually of course of course
that's a no-brainer porn stars yeah yeah
we're like porn
well in brazil you could [ __ ] go to a
club at 14.
yeah so you know i feel like you're like
an adult at four i feel like a lot of
the world you can just kind of go out
when you're
yeah as long as you look old enough to
drink it then you can do it
don't worry about it nicole schumacher
says y'all are the reason i listen to
podcasts now
oh yeah wow that's quite a compliment
i don't even know like i don't even this
show is just so
cobbled together yeah
we just have like no organization no
nothing about anything
he doesn't he doesn't even usually know
what the topic is until he sits down
he knew this time because because it was
the poll and like
he knew and he was like oh goody because
he knew about howard he is
but yeah so howard hughes um you know
after all of that talk about swanson tv
did that's how we started talking about
because we talked about swanson tv
dinners and we got into school lunches
and then yeah he went to that [ __ ]
he went in this you we see how that
happens so uh yeah so for the next 10
years he gets seen very
seldom um you know he's basically like
saying he's doing the [ __ ] where he's
like hey i'm gonna go into this like
screening room to check out some movies
that he doesn't come out for four months
and then every now and then like
somebody in his crew goes in there to
check on him and he's sitting there
naked watching movies eating the candy
bar and drinking milk and peeing in a
jar
and his [ __ ] fingernails are growing
like curling like that his hair is all
along and [ __ ] like that he's not
bathing and also that's nice
like mr house from [ __ ] new vegas
that's what i mean it's like there have
been so many [ __ ] fictionals
it's awesome you eventually find mr
house and he's in a hyper he's in a
[ __ ] sleep chamber
and suspended animation you can pull it
out i don't remember you doing that
yeah i found mission and i [ __ ]
pulled his ass out of the [ __ ]
chamber and [ __ ] killed him
he was a bad guy getting a haircut
hippie yeah when i pulled him out he
looked
he looked just like that photograph of
[ __ ] empowered his before he died
like the long grain yeah
long hair and [ __ ] look yeah he
looked like he looked like a homeless
man like a homeless bomb yeah that's
exactly what he looked like which like i
said it's weird that he was so worried
but
it's the same kind of thing because like
you know we we watch hoarders because i
love orders it's like
disgusting but fascinating at the same
time and my grandfather was a hoarder so
i'm kind of like i know about that kind
of [ __ ]
i feel like it's really interesting that
hoarding and ocd are on the same
spectrum
and particularly somebody like howard
hughes whose ocd manifested so much as a
like
germ phobia you would think somebody
like that would want to be
like he would want everything to be like
spotlessly clean
but that did not extend to his own
person
apparently like he was totally fine
yeah he was totally fine with not
cutting his hair not cutting his nails
not bathing
sitting in a room for four months and
peeing and pooping in jars or whatever
it was he was doing
um he was totally fine with that because
he didn't have germs everyone else did
yeah
germs couldn't come from him what you
know what this is a terrible story but
this is
um this is apparently true like several
people that knew howard hughes have
confirmed this
not only was he really like um
was he really like uh afraid of
contagion
that extended he really really really
did not like black people
yeah um he had a a private screening
room
at mgm studios i believe and he would go
in there and watch movies
until the day he found out that the cast
of porgy and bess
which this if anybody that knows
anything about musicals that's an
all-black musical
um had been going in there to watch the
dailies
in which case he was like i'm never
going in there ever again because he
thought it was
polluted black people were in there yeah
because they had touched everything and
it could never be cleaned
isn't that nice but yeah so he yeah he
had issues but there's more to it
there's more to it than the ocd you're
talking about the other book that i read
he had a lot of he had a lot of stuff
that also came from head injuries
constantly repeating the same phrases
over and over again he didn't just get
caught
that was one of the things that alerted
his crew that something was the matter
because he would keep repeating the same
same phrases like 30 times and they'd be
like dude you just said that
and then he had all these rituals he had
to go through to get anything [ __ ]
done
more ocd he wouldn't touch doorknobs he
wouldn't like i said everybody had to
he had like he he probably should have
bought like [ __ ]
stock and kleenex he might have because
he went through so much clean he wore
clean xboxes on his feet
he had like his he had kleenex like all
over his hands everybody that worked for
him had to put kleenex and [ __ ]
they had everything they handed him they
had to like put layers of kleenex on
their hands to like
hand it to him or like touch him like
they hand in the phone or something he
was [ __ ] nuts
yeah there was also the thing about this
maybe was before he went into his
seclusion he had a big thing
for this particular brand of banana nut
ice cream
and he really really loved it and he
would eat it all the time
but then the company that made it um
said that they discontinued the flavor
and he was really upset
so he went to the factory and they said
well
you know we don't make it anymore uh
you'd have to buy at least 350 gallons
of it
like for us to make a round for make it
and he's like okay well i'll do that so
he pays for 350 gallons of banana dot
ice cream
so he buys it he gives it to the hotel
where he's staying
and then he decides he's sick of banana
nut ice cream and decides he wants
french vanilla ice cream instead so this
hotel has 350 [ __ ] gallons of banana
nut ice cream in their freezers that
they don't know what to do with and they
just started like giving it away to
people because
he ordered all of it because he wanted
it and then he didn't want it anymore
and i think it was um
what was the girlfriend that gave him a
hard time constantly the [ __ ] one
that he
probably really loved what was her name
who katherine hepburn kevin
i think it was katherine hedburn him and
catherine liked this special orange ice
cream now it wasn't
orange sherbet it was like a cream
ice cream that had oranges in it they
don't make a lot they don't make that
they should it's probably yeah and it
was somewhere on the eastern [ __ ]
seaboard that made it
and he was living in california at the
time
they started talking about it and he
sent an airplane from california to all
the way i think it was
to near new york somewhere around that
time to get a
to get some of that ice cream and come
back and they and and uh
they [ __ ] wherever they're doing like
a foot this marathon [ __ ]
mission like a relay race handed it off
to other airplanes
to get it in in like 12 hours it
actually kind of broke a record
yeah yeah so like really fast airplanes
to [ __ ] bring them this [ __ ] ice
cream
and that i've never wanted ice cream
that and it was only like five or ten
gallons we're not talking about like a
whole bunch of ice cream
a small thing of ice cream really and
the book the guy in the book said that
that ice cream if they added all up was
like ten thousand dollars of the of
money back then
right like i said i've never wanted ice
cream probably i don't think i've ever
wanted anything that bad
yeah so probably hundreds of thousands
of dollars spent on that ice cream but
really money didn't mean anything to him
that's what i mean i guess if you're
rich and you can just have whatever you
want
like that kind of [ __ ] and you don't
really the thing about having that
that much money you don't have to worry
about anything you don't have
anything you don't have to do anything
you don't have to do anything
so i feel like and somebody like howard
hughes in particular
would get really wrapped up in these
little bitty insignificant
kind of details so that would just be
like this big mission we're gonna get
this particular flavor of ice cream
and i have the money and you can just do
it and it's like
to the rest of us peons down here that
like you know struggle to pay bills
it just seems really frivolous and
annoying
because you just get these dudes like oh
i decided that i wanted this particular
flavor of ice cream that only this one
artisanal place
like in italy sells so i'm just gonna
pay millions of dollars to have some
[ __ ] like fly it over here to me
you know what i mean but i guess to them
it doesn't seem that weird because
like what the [ __ ] else have they got to
do no it wasn't dreamsicle it was
orange ice cream and i've never
heard of it really or seen it like a
cream
like a vanilla ice cream is what that
had oranges in it
and like i don't know if it had oranges
and like orange
swirl in it that's based on memory
it was more of a cream ice cream yeah
flavored with orange
sounds good but i've never seen anything
like it i gotta say that like one of the
i'm not super into like fruity ice
creams if i'm gonna eat ice cream it's
gonna be
like coffee flavor with like chocolate
chips or nuts in it or it's gonna be
some crunchy or it's gonna be like
peppermint candy or something
um all but no they're not they're all
the same they like that [ __ ] same
flavors of ice cream
they don't liking that fruit ice cream
men like fruit ice cream
right i've known a lot of women that
like fruit ice cream i just i personally
don't
um i don't like any i don't like fruit
and milk together usually
all right um so ice cream like i said i
usually butter pecan
or you know coffee or mint chocolate
chip or you know peppermint stick or
something like that i like that kind of
[ __ ] or moose tracks or something
um however i will say that
a couple of the indian restaurants here
in town do
a mango ice cream it's not sherbet yeah
it's ice cream
and they make it like in and it is
delicious i don't even i don't even like
mangoes
but that [ __ ] [ __ ] is delicious yeah
and it's like bright orange
i don't know i would do it on time for
the show two hours and 23 minutes
how much we have left i don't know okay
i guess we'll find out
this could be a four hour show i don't
know maybe okay
um somebody earlier said that i'd
obviously never smoked weed if i
never wanted ice cream that bad i've
always i've smoked wheat a couple of
times but it's like mostly it didn't
make me hungry it just made me really
paranoid
i didn't care for it but um yeah i've
never wanted
ice cream that badly so yeah
anyway so over the following decade like
i said he's kind of like
mostly kind of incognito and letting his
inner circle kind of run [ __ ]
he didn't even show up like he got
accused um
uh of like any trust like monopoly type
[ __ ]
uh about his twa shares
and he was supposed to like comment like
uh in front of the
you know hearing about that and he
didn't show up
so he actually lost control of the
business
you know by default because he didn't
show up um he actually ended up selling
his
shares for 500 million dollars so again
even when he doesn't do [ __ ]
he still makes money see alex is right
he says moose tracks is effeminate that
[ __ ] is a feminine
chocolatey shit's a family man no
i mean well i always thought i always
thought fruit ice cream was more way
more offensive no i don't think so
it's fruity you're just you're a fruit
chocolate
chocolate there's something feminine
about chocolate i don't know what it is
it seems like women gravitate towards
all that chocolatey stuff
chocolatey stuff with nutty stuff and
[ __ ] and
and and and i like sherbet really
intense
and when you eat you always like fruity
like he likes
gummy bears and like you know cherries
mike and ike's [ __ ] jelly belly he
bought he seriously he went to sam's the
other day
and he brought back this is what he
brought back you guys
we're trying not to get fat she's making
fun of me he brought back
a big box of nutty buddy little debbies
yeah big box of uh hostess coffee cakes
those are good though
i have those they're they're small so i
i have one for breakfast
good coffee yeah or for like a afternoon
coffee break
um also you got a big you got uh another
box of like another
kind too did you get more oatmeal cream
pies no oh you still had some of those
left
and he bought a big huge bag of mike and
ike's yeah like five pounds
and a big huge bag of jelly bellies
wasn't a bag it was a [ __ ] jar a big
jar like a five pound jar which is good
because i don't like those so you can
eat all of them and get fat gourmet
jelly beans
if you're gonna if you're gonna go to
sam's and buy candy buy fruit candy
because i'm not gonna eat it
i don't like it see i'd like juji fruits
[ __ ] gummy bears
see it's just to me it seems like a
waste of calories skittles
the only fruity candies i like i like i
like life savers
although butter rum ones are better than
jolly ranchers uh jolly ranchers are
okay and starburst
like those too but if i'm gonna pay for
candy and i'm gonna eat
like 300 400 calories worth of candy
because that's like a big cal
a calorie you know thing for the day
i want it to be something like
substantial
i like that scandinavian black licorice
what's that that's [ __ ] big old
things are black but
it's almost like eating [ __ ] jerky
like they're good like i don't hate them
they're good
but it's like i would just rather if i'm
gonna if i'm gonna eat like
candy i would rather have something like
a chocolate bar with nuts in it or like
a ferrero rocher
or something a little more with a little
more heft
you know what i mean fruity candy seems
just kind of like insubstantial and like
blah
there's something about chocolate a
woman eats it and it releases some kind
of hormones it's something sexual it's
something
it's not sexual it's just it's the feel
good hormones something
it's something it's the feel good
chemical it feels estrogenic to me when
i eat it no
it's just it does it to everybody like
chocolate releases like the happiness
chemical like in your brain it doesn't
it's not just women it does it for
everybody
all right it makes you happy like in the
same way that sex makes you happy
i'm getting sleepy chocolate does that
for everybody i'm getting sleepy
don't you [ __ ] bow out of me it's
only two and a half hours all right man
you're wearing me out with this [ __ ]
show
i'm wearing you out all right
dude it's 7 23 p.m i'm fine
you know what i made it's like it's not
even it's not even late
it's not even okay let's go let's change
the subject tammy says my husband
actually has a junk food cupboard he
gains no weight see dudes are the worst
i can't get away with like i said i have
to curate
my snacking because i'm one of those
people that it's like
i've said this before on the show
probably i sniff a cupcake
i gained five pounds so it's like if i'm
gonna have a snack
it better be something [ __ ] good that
i really want
because i can't i can't just
i lift and i take well i exercise too
but it's just like you can't i
i just gain weight really easily in a
way that you don't
so i really have to think about like how
badly
do i want this snack right now and if
it's just going to be gummy bears or
something it's not worth it to me it's
not what i lift and i take a bunch of
weird high-performance [ __ ] so
it's hard you know it's easy for me to
keep it off i'm constantly in build mode
well dudes in general um don't store fat
the same way that women do
because of testosterone it's very
frustrating because it's like they can
it you know when when you get older it
evens out
but i mean i used to like when my
brother was a kid
holy crap that child would just eat and
eat and eat and eat and i didn't know
where he was putting it he was like
skinny
well i started too fast now but i
started to get chubby and that's why i
started to lift it started to [ __ ]
reverse a lot of that
well like i said when you get old you
can't yeah you have to keep your heart
but when dudes are young
it's like you really you can eat a lot
you can get away with eating a lot and
you won't gain it yeah it's hormones
women don't have that level but you can
keep those hormones in balance
through a bunch of different means you
either [ __ ]
naturally or you can [ __ ] get
external assistance
yeah i mean it's michael schaefer says
tom is an old man does he eat dinner at
4 30.
i eat whenever the [ __ ] i want to eat we
actually ate
at well we ate before the show yeah we
ate it like four probably i
made some [ __ ] chinese food it was
good like chinese pork with broccoli and
yeah cherries chinese onions and peppers
and stuff yeah
and it was all very high in protein that
was
kind of it's lunch slash dinner because
we didn't really have
i mean we had brunch we had egg
sandwiches at like 11.
like just eggs on like a pita i'm
convinced that it
e your diet is important it should be
heavy in protein
you got to keep it kind of low in
carbohydrates
you got to have a lot of nutrients there
when you get older you might want to
take
vitamins all right but then you also
have to have [ __ ] high output
you gotta [ __ ] you gotta lift weights
cardio isn't enough
your body responds to that in a certain
way keeps your hormones in a certain
kind of balance
you got to be in fight-or-flight mode
which keeps you in like [ __ ] build
in build mode that's why those dudes are
taking [ __ ] like growth hormones that
keeps them in build mode
that way you're not sitting around
getting fat and girlish
because being girlish is the worst just
become you just your hormones get out of
whack
he tries to say it's like he's always
like everything everything about girls
is bad nah that's
she's reading into it ice cream flavors
are girly
chocolate ice cream is girly i'm just
playing but
that'll that'll happen girls suck for
the worst no
when a man gets overweight does not look
like a girl i'm just [ __ ] with it
no he looks like a fat he looks like a
fat old man
but i gotta i gotta i gotta [ __ ] you
know i gotta put gravy on top of it
mark says when men get old they look
like sean connery when women get old
they look like shawn cutter
yeah yeah
it's sad but true it's hormones and you
know
we live in 2020
[Laughter]
there are ways there are hormone
replacement therapies out there
and there's [ __ ] ways of keeping
yourself in shape
if you don't do it you gotta shape you
die
you're gonna die anyway but you know
just depends on if you want to die good
looking or you want to die whole you
know ugly you know
it's on you it's on you it's your choice
is yours you're the one that ate a whole
bowl of jelly beans like i can eat a
whole bowl of jelly beans though man
[ __ ]
we'll see i'm sore as [ __ ] i'm not going
to eat any jelly
yeah because he's like hey want jelly
beans i'm like no i don't want it like i
said
it wasn't a whole bunch i had a bowl
there was only it was only about that
that much in the bottom of them it was
about like uh
about like what would be in a pack of
skittles a little bit more yeah
like i said if i'm gonna eat candy yeah
i want some good [ __ ] candy i don't
just want some jelly beans you know what
i'm saying what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i lost my connection you
did yeah oh no we gotta get back in
there
well hopefully we didn't we're still on
right it looks like i think so
all right yeah so like i said so
howard's been like in his
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he's not like
communicating with anybody
so he loses his uh share of twa now
at some point he moves into the
penthouse
uh at the desert inn in las vegas
famously
now he's up there how old is he by this
time um
this was in uh [ __ ] 1967.
okay so he's in his 40s already yeah
okay or 50s actually 50s
probably in his 50s at this point
because he was born in 1904
yeah so this was 1967.
so uh so him and his entourage like his
crew and stuff
uh they have like the penthouse at the
desert inn in vegas
and he's been he's there for a couple
months
and evidently the owners of the
hotel were not super happy about it
because they're like look um
people have reserved the penthouse you
know for
various dates and stuff like you do and
uh so we would like you to leave please
because you're really kind of hogging
the whole penthouse floor that other
people have reserved
and uh howard hughes got kind of shirty
and did not want to leave
so he bought the whole hotel
yeah just so he wouldn't have to leave
that's how you handle because that's
just
if you have the money i guess he's just
like everyone stop bitching at me here
cha-ching so he buys the whole hotel now
because he bought the desert inn this
kind of gave him the idea hey
now i'm going to become like a real
estate investor
in las vegas and he proceeds to buy
a whole bunch of other hotels and
casinos in las vegas and a bunch of land
so he bought i think he ended up buying
like seven other hotels like the silver
slipper
like a whole bunch of other like kind of
iconic ones a lot of them are gone now
um but yeah so he owned like a large
part of las vegas
and like i mentioned earlier in the show
it was probably
this particular purchase that spurred
other investors to come to las vegas
and buy property and stuff and kind of
they didn't drive the mafia out
but it kind of changed the public
perception of las vegas as
this kind of like mafia-owned hell hole
um to somewhere that like tourists could
go like families could go like [ __ ] like
that so it made it more like
attractive to investors and tourists
because it wasn't seen as just like this
mafia-owned
city anymore so
um there was also okay so like i said
there's all this like creepy [ __ ] going
around this time we've talked about like
the fingernails and the pooping in
jars and earth yeah and he wasn't like
that all the time
no it was weird because it was like
intermittent
intermittent and like sometimes he
seemed to have
like for long periods he seemed to like
not really be aware of it but then
suddenly
somebody would say something to him
about it and it would like
kind of shake him out of it and he would
like go and get a haircut and buy a new
suit and like come out in public and be
like see i'm fine
now let me describe this a little bit in
the book that i read his right hand man
described the way it was
his head injuries and his problems would
cause him to repeat himself over and
over again
and it would embarrass him yeah so to
save himself from the embarrassment he
would go hide out in that damn theater
for months at a time yeah just watching
movies sitting there naked
and during that time somehow he would
kind of overcome it
and it would it would sometimes he'd
relapse
into this and during that time where he
was
having to face that senate hearing about
the [ __ ]
the war profiteering yeah he really
glitched out over that
all right it was either that or there
was another one later about t.w.a
that was another antitrust thing he was
glitching the [ __ ] out over
over that one and so he hid out for a
long time
and then what was funny is like on the
eve of that hearing he reappears
of disheveled old [ __ ] repeat
the shiva [ __ ]
cleans himself up puts on this fantastic
shirt
and walks right into that [ __ ] senate
hall and gives this [ __ ] like
badass defense and they were amazed
because just hours before that he was
just [ __ ] insane
yeah yeah and he didn't have moments of
lucidity yeah and then
he goes back and he rode a high horse
for a long time after that like he had
recovered
but whenever he was stressed out over
something he'd relapse
yeah back into this [ __ ] constant
repetition in an ocean yeah it's like he
would kind of get back into this pattern
that it was really hard for him to get
out of
and then at the last minute he'd have to
face some trial
like another [ __ ] trial in in public
and then he'd
pull it out again and [ __ ] have this
tremendous [ __ ] it seems like if he
had
something to motivate him whether it was
like
um you know a new conquest like a new
like woman that he was really interested
in or a new project
yeah or like someone that was like
[ __ ] with him and he just like wanted
to fight it
it seemed like he needed that motivation
to kind of like come out of it
and overcome his mental illness for a
short time but it was only for a short
time like it was
you know it would eventually get the
better of him again which was
like i said kind of sad because it seems
like he didn't really have a lot of
choice i think he inherited that
propensity for
ocd from his mom because i think she had
it as well and then
you know the fact of his high-risk
lifestyle let's call it that
um with you know getting syphilis from
all the
promiscuity and also like all the head
injuries from the crashes it's like that
really didn't and the drug abuse as it
went on
the book i read did not mention anything
about the syphilis although
that's a possibility they had that back
then well yeah because well because um
one of the women needs was atlanta
turner she had syphilis as well although
i think that was later
so he she might have got it from him
because i think that was like before
but i'm you know the biography i read
came out in 2014 so
it's fairly recent what was funny is
that it was treatable it was curable in
his day
but he didn't it was if he had it it
means he wasn't going for the cure
like i said he would he distrusted
penicillin but he did like
do like the older dumbass cure for it
which gave him a lot of other side
effects
and like i said because he was in so
many plane crashes
and had so many problems because so many
head injuries like
punctured lung all that other kind of
stuff so he was on all kind of
painkillers
most of which were obtained illegally
and like a lot of his doctors
uh one in particular got in trouble
later on because they found out that
he was actually illegally obtaining a
lot of those drugs for him because he
wasn't really supposed to have them like
a lot of doctors are glorified drug
dealers that's
well that's his definitely was i mean
you can see why he did it because i mean
i guess he could see that howard was in
terrible pain all the time because of
all his injuries
but he still needed to get out and do
[ __ ] so he was just like trying to
keep him going i guess yeah so he just
like like i said so he was uh
he was a drug addict really i mean he
was on codeine and he was on
like various other things and he could
take so much of it
that i mean it was just like he could
take an amount that would kill a normal
person
just because he had like worked up yeah
so much
yes because he just had to keep taking
more and more which like i said was
which causes arm because elvis had the
same kind of thing where they kept
giving him all these painkillers
and the longer you're on those and if
you have other issues as well
then it just all kind of keeps feeding
back into itself because
the drugs they give you like i said they
cause constipation they cause like all
these other health issues
and then you have to take other drugs to
alleviate that and then you
you know things like this big [ __ ]
spiral codeine and
morphine type drugs opiates they put you
into a mental bubble too
where you're in your own little world
and it's kind of a world of fantasy and
self-delusion
which wouldn't help a dude like hughes
yeah he's in the middle of a [ __ ]
empire
you know what i mean be real easy
to convince yourself that reality
doesn't apply to you
and i think it's part of like he
definitely does
seem like somebody that thought that he
could transcend
he could do it in reality yeah this
doesn't work and
it might be because of his upbringing
like i said because he was raised very
rich and he could kind of like have
whatever he wanted
yeah um so
and then the fact that he inherited the
company when he was very young he was
only 19 and he was like you know a
millionaire a billionaire already
and i don't know i don't i don't think
that's very healthy
when you think about it it's almost kind
of like eternal childhood isn't it
a lot of people said that about him that
he was just like a kid
essentially he had never really grown up
no well he never really had to
no real challenges i mean he did
like you know he did like daring [ __ ]
like he you know he flew around the
world he could fly planes he did this
and the other thing
but it did really seem like a lot of
people that knew him said that he had
never really grown up or never really
matured
he never had any hardship in his life
really well he's volunteering himself
for hardship trying to earn scores
points yeah i definitely think that's
the issue that when he's trying to break
those records
which is what i was trying to say in
earlier shows that's what tom cruise did
when he tried to [ __ ] join
scientology
yeah he was a man who had it made
pampered kind of guy who came from
nothing he came from nothing
pretending that he's a hero in these
movies and pretending that he's a man of
action
but he doesn't have those credentials
he's not ex-military he's not ex-law
enforcement he never takes real risks
so how does he get these credentials he
can't join the army he can't become a
cop but he can join scientology
yeah and they can make him a [ __ ]
wizard make a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] give him training on riding
you know him and [ __ ] david miscavige
riding the [ __ ] ducatis around and
shooting guns in the secret [ __ ]
scientology basis
out in the middle of [ __ ] the desert
with the [ __ ] sacred text of l ron
hubbard and [ __ ] everywhere and he can
be [ __ ]
special because only a scientology of
course can
help a person have an accident and jump
out of a car and save a [ __ ]
because they're the only ones that would
do that exactly they're the only ones
that would do that it's just the
scientology you know
a regular non-scientologist would never
do such a thing [ __ ] no public
we would never stop to help a person
that was in pain that had been in an
accident
only scientology special force is also
known as the fact that he actually
believes that is kind of mind-blowing to
me
that's mind-blowing well like i said on
other shows
being an ex-thespian myself
and no one having friends you know
ex-girlfriends that are [ __ ]
hollywood stars and [ __ ]
they're they they they're they're
pampered they're they're not real people
they're not real people they're
pretenders adult pretenders
well you don't really i mean once you
have a certain amount of money and i
think howard hughes really applies in
this case too
it's like once you have a certain amount
of money you're really buffered from
the you know the kind of like vestiges
of life that
a lot of us regular joes have to put up
with and then they
tell them to get in front of television
and give people advice
on how to [ __ ] live their lives i
don't think that's for me don't take
advice from a [ __ ] house
well i don't take advice from anybody
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about i'm like are you me
no then shut up yeah
[Laughter]
it's [ __ ] funny i don't like to give
advice that's why that's why l ron
hubbard wanted
he wanted celebrities in scientology
because even back in his day he knew
that celebrities had a lot of pull with
the public you know what i mean like oh
yeah
he's a scientologist well he's famous so
let's listen to what he has to do
even though he's a total idiot and if
he's a scientologist then scientology
must be good
it would never be something like a ufo
cult or anything like that no
no how could that be it could never be a
ufo cult anybody that would listen to a
[ __ ] celebrity on anything it's like
i don't [ __ ] know
it's like people listen to jenny
mccarthy about [ __ ] vaccines [ __ ]
alex is just saying my name
laughing alex i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about bro you can't just
say my name and laugh
all right you're just funny in general
he's just laughing at your entire life
what i'm saying but yeah so well that's
what i'm saying like everything that i
read about howard hughes i'm not like
[ __ ] on him or anything like that
but
it does seem like dudes like howard
hughes
that are very intelligent um but have
grown up in a very privileged uh
you know manner it does seem that they
are
constantly constantly trying to prove
something to the world
you know what i mean i mean just like
with all the women with all the records
he was trying to like with all the [ __ ]
that he was trying to do he was always
trying to like
i admire it though at least he tried to
do do something he didn't sit around
yeah you didn't just sit around
someone sit around get fat which a lot
of them would have
yeah i've been sitting around and get
fat and just hired hookers to come over
and blow them
that's what they did i don't even have
to be good looking for you [ __ ]
i'll just [ __ ] i can just lay with my
big belly same way can we even find the
move the belly yeah to the sides i don't
need to be good-looking you're just a
[ __ ]
yeah that's so at least he [ __ ] he
was he's a man
he's all right and like i said a lot of
the women that dated him even though he
did some shitty like unquestionable
things
uh particularly concerning some of the
young engineers that came there like
their careers with the contracts and
stalking them and whatnot um a lot of
the women that dated him and were
friends with him
did actually um they recognized that he
had some issues that he was uh very
insecure that he had
like some other that he was very
ruthless in business but a lot of them
did seem to like him as a person
yeah he was a man of his time yeah and
um he was a good man but he wasn't in
i think the best of situations when it
came to developing
really good character yeah you know what
i mean uh you it's difficult
to be that wealthy and develop really
good character it is
to develop really good character you
have to know both sides of the fence you
have to have some suffering
yeah and he did run from it so maybe he
suffered a little bit
then but it has to happen in your early
childhood development
yeah i mean he's never going to have the
same character right
i guess or the same struggle i guess as
someone that
came from came from nothing and [ __ ]
then built themselves up
because he was not really self-made
no he inherited it yeah i mean built
upon him his dad
his family was wealthy you know because
his mom's family was wealthy as well
it wasn't just his death it's very rare
to have somebody who's 100 percent
self-made and have that amount of weight
i don't even know
it's it's it's hard to say it's like
it's the only one maybe zuckerberg
yeah zuckerberg just if you like
invented something
that you know like every elon musk i
think came from nothing didn't he
i'm not well i don't want to answer that
question because i'm not sure i i think
well he just did paypal right
isn't it yeah isn't that how isn't that
where the money first came i think so
yeah i don't think he really
yeah and like i kind of admire like i'm
not saying that like
those are all good people because
they're not but if you just have like a
great
idea and can know how to implement it
like you know i came up with the idea
for facebook i came up with the idea for
paypal whatever
i'm not saying there are great people
i'm just saying i admire that more than
some guy that comes out and says i'm a
self-made millionaire even though
you know you get all this money from
your parents and you have all these
connections already
it's like yeah it's easier for you it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter where
you can come from nobody's perfect
uh but i think zuckerberg elon musk
the guy that [ __ ] owns amazon what's
his [ __ ] name again
george uh jeff bezos bezos yeah all
those dudes basically came from nothing
they were just computer nerds that came
from nothing and they all ended up a
little bit different
none of them are perfect um
but you know even though those guys are
very different and i think the public
has a very different
opinion of each one of those depending
on what side of the aisle you fall on
those are all good men they all have
different opinions i don't agree
with all of them all right but they're
all good men they're all
they're all doing what they think is
right um
i think they're i think they were cut
above of the billionaires of the past of
the 20s and the 30s
i think they're well a lot of those came
for money yeah that's what i'm saying
not always like every now and then you'd
get a guy that just had like a really
good
business idea the size of the robber
likes enough money but that was rare
most of them were descendants of robber
barons
yeah because i feel like the the myth of
like the self-made man that is largely a
myth
well they have them they do like i said
every now and then you do get a dude
it's like
i came to the united states you know
they were an immigrant and i
only had five dollars in my pocket and
like i scripted and i had like a food
truck
and now i own taco bell or whatever
here's something it's like but that's
very rare it's usually you have to have
it is very rare but you know what most
of the robber barons were like that
yeah most of the robber bears uh who was
the guy that owned the railroads um
irishman he came without a pot to piss
and he was a [ __ ] gangster
yeah you guys know who i'm talking about
what's his name i can't remember his
name right now
yeah he was the uh he was the guy who
owned the railroads yeah there was a lot
he was an old irishman and that dude
there he was a [ __ ] gangster
uh but he came with nothing so just
so that's another thing just because you
were an uh
an old school american robber baron that
doesn't mean you were born with a silver
spoon in your mouth either
quite the contrary late 1800s 1800s you
were you were a ruthless gangster most
likely
street gangster yeah and then the
subsequent generation i do feel like a
lot of those
people were vanderbilt that's right yeah
vanderbilt yeah
um you know it's it's much easier to
make
a business if you already have money and
you already have connections
that's all i'm saying i mean obviously
wait a minute no
vanderbilt carnegie rockefeller
carnegie and carnegie was uh andrew
carnegie was steel
yeah i can't remember rockefeller was
oil
hi pookie vanderbilt was uh [ __ ]
newspapers
carnegie i think was the was this was
the uh was
railroads vanderbilt was newspaper
was he though yeah yeah vanderbilt i
think was a newspaper that was the media
empire
i don't think that was vanderbilt i
think that was um what's his [ __ ]
face
christ i can't remember either oh no
pookie don't please don't don't step on
[ __ ] pokey
go around cookie likes to walk across
keyboards yeah she's like oh
it's so warm and it has squishy brushes
warm and it's squishy yeah
she tried to pull the buttons off my
mind down come on down
yeah carnegie was steel yeah that's what
i thought i think
that's what i thought i had to go on the
internet and [ __ ] [ __ ] all these
people up and show them
yes william of hearst was newspapers
thank you that's right
i went to hell it was like i was like it
was the guy with the [ __ ] rosebud
yeah that's right i went to her that guy
i went to hearst
castle in california when i was a little
kid my mom took me yeah vanderbilt was
shipping in railroad that's right that's
right
okay alex says i'm trying to sort it all
out i went to hearst house
it's called hearst castle he used to be
able to [ __ ] buy a tour
back in the late set of the 70s when i
was a kid my mom took me there
and it was so [ __ ] big especially the
outside that it scared me
i was afraid it's [ __ ] trembling
because he had
a like a parthenon like greek temple and
all these [ __ ] greek fountains with
[ __ ] gargoyles that spit
water and gigantic [ __ ] marble
statues
and [ __ ] greek gods i was [ __ ]
terrified
what you doing poke she's tearing up no
pat all the padded envelopes i have
stacked over there yeah but if you guys
want to look at hearst castle that's
just [ __ ] his trip
poke you settle the [ __ ] down okay she's
like no
she's just she's ignoring me she's like
no i'm just gonna do
poopy's gonna pokey yeah that's just
what she does don't tear a paper
don't tear up paper but yeah so i do
feel like
you know as as interesting as i find
howard hughes it's not like he
you know came out of nowhere came out of
nothing he basically
inherited his dad's business and
like i said he wasn't um
he wasn't the best businessman it's just
he had all this money and he could do
whatever he wanted with it
and it happened that he you know made a
lot of like innovations
just because that's what he was into
what are you doing nope
oh you got it she's like what
why did you why did you take me away she
loves
she doesn't have to take paper she just
wants to love staring at paper she wants
attention
yeah so yeah so howard hughes is in
seclusion
for a long time like a lot of people
don't know where he is
i forgot to even mention like earlier on
like when he was 19 years old
he married a debutant i think her name
is ella rice
and basically he did the same [ __ ] to
her
that he had done that his dad had done
to his mom it was basically like he
married her and then he's just like bye
yeah and he like took off for hollywood
and she's like are we gonna be like
married or
no i'm married or not and he's just like
yeah um don't come out here i have like
too much [ __ ] to do and it's like so
every time she wanted to come out and
visit
every time she wanted to like hey let's
have christmas together every day he
would always like think of some excuse
like i'm always i'm working on a movie
i'm doing this that the other thing so
it always seemed like he was trying to
avoid her
she even like came to like she left them
a bunch of times because she knew about
like all the [ __ ] womanizing and
stuff
and she kind of put up with it for a
while and then like after she was just
like [ __ ] i'm out of here
she divorced him uh yeah she did finally
but um she even came to
when they were going through the divorce
i think she even came to visit him a
hospital like after one of his plane
crashes
and he was like totally he was a total
dick to her he was just kind of like
what are you doing here why did you come
here i don't want you here get out
and she was like just okie doke
and she just kind of got out of there
now he did um
he had made like a provision for her
that he was gonna give her i don't
remember how much it was i think it was
50
000 a year like for the rest of her like
an annuity like for the rest of her life
but later on like when his company got
into trouble
um it didn't like the payment didn't go
through
like one year and like her lawyer like
got crawled up his ass and everything
that was like this big [ __ ] problem
but yeah he was actually married like i
said two times
that they have records of um
maybe three times because terry moore
who was an actress
she actually said that when she was like
a young starlet
that howard hughes had like taken her
out on his yacht
and married her out there and there was
paperwork just so he could
have sex with her and then afterward he
threw the paperwork overboard so there
was no
uh record of it so
that might have been a might have been a
third she said she was married him for a
long time i don't know if that's the
case because there's no record of it he
must have settled out of court with him
but
it she he did actually he did later
actually give her a sum of money
but um that that it sounds crazy but
that
sounds like something that he would do
because like pretty much a lot of
other women that he dated said that he
would say all kind of [ __ ] to them like
oh i'm gonna marry you or i married you
like
in god's eyes or whatever just so he
could get him into bed and then he'd be
like yeah whatever
well he figured they needed an excuse
yeah
that's probably what he figured that's
probably well they're under all these
societal pressures that they have to be
married so
i'm gonna go ahead and take the pressure
off of him i'm gonna tell you that's
what he did
so go ahead and give it up baby that's
exactly what it is of course that's what
he did
it worked a few times some of the women
were just like yeah no they didn't fall
for it but because even back then people
were
well for him it didn't matter if he
married him for real or in god's eyes
it's gonna be about the same anyway
yeah it really didn't seem to matter
it's like i don't even really know why
he bothered to like marry the two women
that he did or three
women that he did marry it's like why
bother yeah because it just seems it's
on a whim when he's gonna cheat on him
anyway
he's like two it's like he's gonna
disappear he's never seen it he's gonna
disappear and never like
be like their husband anyway so it's
just like why
he was the marriage type why bother with
him that's what i mean it's like i don't
understand why he
why he even bothered so yeah um
so he was basically in seclusion for
pretty much a decade
now the last time that he came out into
public was because this happened in 1971
there was a huge scandal about
um there was this book that was
supposedly coming out that were
supposedly his
memoirs now the person that wrote it
said that they had been like
interviewing him and they'd been in
contact and they've been talking with
him and this was
all fine with him and he had signed all
these papers and [ __ ]
and he the guy that wrote the book like
had had the manuscript and it was going
to be published
and everything was all fine he had all
these papers that were supposedly signed
by howard hughes saying it was all right
and so howard hughes had to come
out of his reclusive state
to say that this was [ __ ] because it
was like a whole
one million dollar like [ __ ] book
deal for this [ __ ] which
1971 that was a lot of money so um
you know so there was like this big
controversy about it and actually it was
significant because that was the last
time that howard hughes was seen
in public was him coming out and saying
hey this whole book thing that's
happening that led me back i didn't talk
to that guy
let me back up a little bit during all
this time going all the way back to his
[ __ ]
chase and tail days with all these young
starlets at rko
he had built the world's largest and
greatest intelligence organization and
it was [ __ ]
extremely adept at counter intelligence
to get in other words how to foil
[ __ ] intelligence agents tapping your
phones
he could do that all right yeah it was
it was it was [ __ ] uh uh what's his
name
what was the name of his security agency
do you remember no
um it's not right it doesn't matter yeah
it doesn't matter
[Laughter]
he decided in his wisdom and it
it might have been very wise that in his
inhu i think it was just called a huge
security probably and you knew
everything
yeah i was going to call it huge
security in his security he decided to
recruit only from the mormon population
yeah for a long time because they didn't
drink they didn't drink
they didn't smoke they were clean-cut
and good-looking kind of mostly blonde
kind of guys he thought they were
trustworthy
and and he saw them as
tolerant of his lifestyle of having lots
of women
okay because you know the mormon church
had a reputation for bigamy yeah well
then multiple marriage i'm not gonna
call it big me multiple marriage
so he saw them as being friendly to his
lifestyle
and he invented a lot of money and a lot
of technology to develop
the technological tools that these guys
would need
okay they had two
missions monitor and protect his harem
that was [ __ ] wrong one okay don't
let him do anything don't let them
[ __ ] give out that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] if they're giving it out
let me know that was pretty
that was like priority number one
priority one he wasn't even banging him
usually
he had so many he just didn't want him
banging anyone else or doing anything
else could not
give away any [ __ ] if you worked for
[ __ ] howard and you were one of his
starlets
you're gonna you can try to [ __ ] find
reason in that all day long but you just
cannot [ __ ]
expect to find reason in theology and
[ __ ] was his religion
okay now it was it does seem like that
yeah i think it was
that was what he spent
[ __ ] was his religion okay he had not
transcended
[ __ ] him he had not transcended that
that [ __ ] well man i feel so drunk i
can't [ __ ] talk about this [ __ ]
he has not he did not transcend the
addiction
of it you know what i mean he had to
have it he couldn't take it or leave it
so he's kind of weak to it stop it poop
stop it i'm talking about [ __ ]
[Laughter]
don't talk to her like that she's just a
baby she doesn't understand
anyway talking like that in front of our
second mission
pookie i told you i said do not that
that is already labeled to go to a
customer and she tried to hide
underneath it she was like what i didn't
she can she can tear up one like when
she's if she wants now
mission two by all accounts mission one
[ __ ] mission one [ __ ] protection
okay that's the first one mission two
okay
do not allow the fbi to know anything
about howard hughes
yeah that's what he was really he was
super paranoid about that
he thought they were watching him which
they actually did have him under
surveillance for a time but because of
the anti-trust stuff it wasn't like for
any other he was kind of paranoid though
fbi
if the fbi thought howard hughes is
crazy and they were afraid that he would
crash the economy
yeah like like i said that was a
legitimate conflict it was
it was half true he could have crashed
the economy probably
he probably could have sure and he was
crazy so they were correct
he said something sideways on television
one time and it caused a [ __ ] stock
market fluctuation
that happened and that's when he kind of
came under scrutiny
yeah the fbi was like what was the guy
who ran the fbi as a [ __ ] he was a
notorious
[ __ ] one hoover hoover yeah hoover
was fascinated was [ __ ]
absolutely fascinated with him alex says
economies are effeminate
economies are [ __ ] i like how alex
i like how alex thinks if anything
meddles
with your normal man business it's
effeminate
your normal man business whatever that
may be it's just whatever you want if
it starts [ __ ] with you didn't you
got me buried yeah
just just a family i'm taking it back to
the 80s
i'm on the randy macho man savage level
of it
yeah i'm just having fun with these
so where are we so where are we going oh
just you know just rule one and rule two
rule one protect [ __ ] rule two don't
let the fbi know anything
and this [ __ ] created the world's
greatest intelligence organization
the fbi and then later on the cia
actually
learned everything that they eventually
knew from
the huge security organization they
modeled themselves
after his security yeah they were in a
[ __ ]
basically a war with huge security for
decades
yeah that's some [ __ ] cool [ __ ] but
evidently
this security agency got so big
and sprawl and so sprawling
that it kind of ended up doing its own
thing
like no one really knows what that
agency was doing once something gets to
a certain size no one person can be said
to be in control
because there are too many like
mitigating circumstances now because
this agency was so wealthy
and all staffed by mormons and so
powerful
and hughes didn't monitor it really it
ran
as long as it was doing his job he was
like in a [ __ ] room with blackout
curtains
naked peeing in bottles man hughes gave
a [ __ ] what these organizations did as
long as
they fulfilled the the the criteria he
wanted
if there was extra [ __ ] happening he
wouldn't even know about it
so it has been theorized that this
organization when hughes wasn't watching
was absolutely rebuilding [ __ ] in salt
lake city
and and the entire modern mormon church
in all of its glory
actually was was built on huge money
with the huge security agency and with
the muscle that that security agency had
you could leverage local yeah of
authorities you could do all kinds of
[ __ ] make certain laws happen in utah
and you could [ __ ] rule the state of
utah
and with the power that hughes actually
accidentally gave you
yeah yeah he didn't mean to do that
no but the mormon church as you know it
is probably a product side effect
yeah the mormon churches you know it
most likely is
a product of howard hughes and he didn't
even know it
well yeah like i said he was just locked
in a room like worried about flies and
like
and allegedly employing somebody for
eight hours a day
to swat flies away from the door yeah
now that is [ __ ] totally unintended
tended by hughes but i don't want to
talk about bad about the mormon church i
served with mormons and no more
mormons are actually good people and
even though those [ __ ] are kind of
prejudiced against non-mormons it's a
nice town
um some of the cults like the warren
jeff's cult i don't think represents
mainstream
mormonism you know i think that dude is
just a [ __ ] freak
uh most mormonism is about like [ __ ]
any other christian sect
you know um like something you'd find in
southern baptist you know this is just
their own style
but that's and now that money
that built or helped
build salt lake city which that's like
[ __ ] mormon mecca
you know that's their capital city well
yeah that also ended up in a [ __ ]
corporation there's a fast food
chain you would know as a dairy queen
that's mormon dairy queen
which is good good ice cream man that
[ __ ] hit you with that blizzard
or a dilly bird then [ __ ] oh next
thing you know [ __ ] joseph smith
coming at you through the [ __ ] ice
cream
[ __ ] bet you didn't know that did you
every time you got a dilly angel maloney
coming out
coming out of the [ __ ] goddamn
blizzard with the little m
ms and [ __ ] it's beautiful
you didn't know that did you angel
angel's making [ __ ] ice cream
yep the angel moroni is making the
blizzards and the dilly bars
next thing you know you got to live in
newton john [ __ ] singing the grease
[ __ ]
wait was she a mormon she would in
greece
that [ __ ] sandwich oh she was
supposed to be supposed to be a [ __ ]
they just took that out of it it took
that out of the movie it was in the it
was in the
it was in the play sandra d was in the
movie she was just like a square
yeah just a general mormons are squares
well yeah but i mean they didn't like
explicitly
saying she was a mormon yeah she's a
mormon
in the original she was a mormon that's
right i forgot about that
practicing selective reading
i don't know i still think we should do
a whole show on the mormons because
that's a whole
oh man we get the mormons [ __ ] with
us but yeah we could we could do mormon
um that's a whole [ __ ] mormon
mythicism yeah
there's a whole there's a whole story
there's all kinds it's the islam of
america it kind of is
yeah i mean in some ways uh he copied
islam
very definitely he did well like i said
a lot of religions kind of
it's like fanfic they like yeah they
just shift from each other yeah i like
this
aspect let's like spin off a whole kind
of [ __ ] but it's like a whole other
space
i didn't remember the [ __ ] dairy
queen was mormon of course dairy queen
is mormon it is yeah
just like chick-fil-a is a
fundamentalist christian
but they got some [ __ ] ass chicken
sandwiches although
pro tip you can make chick-fil-a
sandwiches yourself
soaking the chicken in pickle juice
pickle juice yeah and then you got a
pressure
secret pickle juice and you got to
pressure cook it yes you batter it and
then pressure cook it in oil
yep yeah that's how you do if you don't
want to go to chick-fil-a
that's how you make the sandwich i've
made them before they're beautiful yes
he has made them before
soak them in pickle juice pressure
they're beautiful they taste
just like chick-fil-a sandwiches yeah so
in case you wanted to know
we should put that in the cookbook
actually yeah yeah we could do that we
need to finish that before the end of
the year holy crap
actually all right look chick-fil-a's
changed the recipe they're not pressure
cooking in oil like they used to it's
slightly different
i do the old-school chick-fil-a like it
was yeah
it's got the batter on it it kind of
tastes like it's fried but not really
that's because they pressure cooked that
[ __ ] in oil yeah
it gives a special it's totally
different when you
have yeah it's just different it's not
crisp
but like is that i think it's the pickle
juice that really yeah
that really makes it exactly brian it's
a brining
you got to soak it actually you got to
soak the breast overnight in a [ __ ]
jar of pickles yeah we put them like in
a big ziploc bag like a gallon ziplock
bag of pickle juice
yeah you want like five because i love
pickles
so we have like those big [ __ ] five
gallon jars yeah pickles like from sam
and then you just dip
you dip it in just normal [ __ ] egg
batter with some and then roll it in
flour
and throw it in a [ __ ] pressure
cooker that's
got a little bit of oil in it and
[ __ ] and it's only a few minutes
yeah and it comes out just like
chick-fil-a exactly the same is that it
is that
exact same soft and then and then a
steamed bun
yeah yeah yeah yeah now we could figure
out how to do the waffle fries
i haven't had a waffle fry waffle i
never have
they're good although i have to say the
waffle fries are good but i don't like
them
as much as the old old kfc used to this
big old
wedge french fries it was just like a
wedge of potato
with the skin on it and they don't do
this anymore
because they're [ __ ] why does
anybody do [ __ ] wedge fries anymore
those are [ __ ] delicious i don't know
i don't get it
but yeah so all right so we're getting
up to the
point now where uh how are you talking
about here and [ __ ]
uh i see mormons walking around in pairs
in their mission but i don't know where
it's
in new york yeah they go to where all
the sinful people are
well around here because where i used to
work the print shop i used to work at
there was a mormon what do they call
their little mormon
they don't call it a church temple yeah
there's a little mormon temple
like maybe three buildings away from
where i worked
they're asking me how long oh go ahead
they're asking
how long in the pickle juice like five
people at least overnight in the
overnight we did it
and and you gotta pressure cook it yeah
all right
get a pressure cooker there are recipes
online the old-school
way to make [ __ ]
chick-fil-a it's any old bun really
you can microwave it with a little bit
of water inside a plastic bag it'll
steam or you could put it in a steamer
you could like well what i used to do
with hot dog buns you just like wrap
them in like a wet paper towel
and they'll like see like 30 seconds
yeah and it's just that breast
it comes right out of the [ __ ]
pressure cooker uh
pickles on it and i think mayonnaise
that's it
yeah chick-fil-a i think there's nothing
on them yeah they just put pickles and
mayonnaise and pickles
that's it that's it which that's all you
need right yeah and you don't want one
of these big ass sanderson farm [ __ ]
you don't want that you want a small
chicken breast
a real chicken breast yeah don't get
like don't get the sandwich in frankie
mississippi [ __ ] chicken i know
sanderson farms that's all [ __ ]
steroid chicken
we bought some chicken breasts from
sands before and they were like this big
yeah well that's a did you even see that
this big and that came from a
mississippi farm called
sanderson's farm those chickens can't
even walk seriously
they sent those chicken breasts to
russia and russia sent them back they
weren't like
they're like yeah that's they're like
that's upsetting chickens don't get that
big there's something wrong
and you're absolutely right they're
correct there's so many [ __ ] growth
hormones in those chickens
and that chicken is almost the size of a
small turkey and it gets that big in two
weeks
from birth yeah and like you know
there's not something
they can't walk they can't even walk
their legs break yeah
it's it's scary yeah like i said we
brought
we bought chicken at sands before and
then brought it back and we were taking
the breasts out and
just freeze them and they were like
they're the same turkey yeah it's like a
turkey breast i'm like holy [ __ ]
and they don't taste and they don't
taste good the texture is all wrong
it's like eating a big ass [ __ ]
scallop
like a real like not even a good scale
not even a good sculpt like a tough
scallop
the texture is not right you want a
little
normal natural chicken breast that's
what you want and that's what they're
making that's what they're making
chick-fil-a with
yeah pickle juice is key pickle juice at
least overnight
yeah just throw it in like just get a
ziploc bag fill it up with pickle juice
throw it in the refrigerator yeah and
just leave it in there overnight and
then the next day stick it in and if
it's in there for two or three days even
better
yeah because it'll all like soak into
the like muscle fibers and it won't rot
in that chicken chicken in that pickled
juice it'll never
juice it'll never go bad juice it'll
never go bad whatever
what about turkey necks says elsa
[Laughter]
i don't know how i don't have the turkey
neck recipe
i gotta call it you put them in your
chest yeah yeah
that's a special mississippi recipe that
only my dad's
black neighbor she's this cute black
woman married
you should call her yeah and she makes
them for my dad
she is the wife of uh
he's a cop no mississippi national guard
he's actually his ex-active military
army in the national
guard he's a [ __ ] uh e7
so he takes care of my dad all this
[ __ ] about [ __ ] race problems in
the united states
that's not the general most people get
along they get along very well you
always
america watches out for especially in
the country areas
your neighbor you always watch out for
you like i said most people are
most people are cool okay people that
get on the news
are you know that exceptions that's why
they're on the news is because they're
an exception most people are all right
yeah so don't worry yeah i when visiting
my dad i grew up in heidelberg
mississippi in laurel mississippi and
heidelberg now all the white people died
my dad is the last of the white man the
last white man
he's the last wife that's the that's the
title of his it's all black
autobiography
yep it's all blessed white man yeah it's
the light
it's a little bitty village there's a
little bitty village built in the in the
city the man made of turkey necks that's
going to be the subtitle yeah i'm going
to write that [ __ ]
it's a little bitty village in the 60s
made in the 60s it looks like 60s and
70s houses
80s houses and all the people that built
that [ __ ]
were all white mississippi people and
they were all old when they built that
[ __ ] it was like a retirement village
almost and they're all dead now
and it's all black middle class now and
they are
experiencing the 1950s they have parades
and they go [ __ ] see movies and they
got a nice high school there and it's
like greece they're living the american
dream it's
a lot of this [ __ ] you're seeing on the
[ __ ] news
is exceptions to the rules most of
america is
totally [ __ ] normal like i said the
reason why
you see things on the news is because
they are accepted yeah it's because they
are quote unquote newsworthy yeah
if it was what everyone was doing it
wouldn't be new yeah were they with it
all the troubles coming from warring
factions they don't have anything to do
with the average person
well like i said that's why i'm not
worried about it but like i said
so turkey next you don't have a you
don't have a recipe i don't know the
recipe my dad said they were [ __ ]
fantastic he was
he kept talking about how good i've
never had turkey necks um
i'm super into turkey though and
thanksgiving is probably my favorite
meal of the year
we always get we always go all out for
thanksgiving man
we usually get two big [ __ ] turkeys
because they're cheap
turkey necks is a southern concept you
know the main [ __ ] and it goes way
back there's a lot of meat on a turkey
neck turkey necks aren't worth anything
you could probably get [ __ ] 20 of
them damn turkey necks for a dollar
fifty i wouldn't mind like grinding it
up and making like a soup out of it
they got bones yeah so you got to slow
cook that [ __ ] you got to pull all the
bones out of them
or you eat it off the bone like like a
chicken wing
yeah but i don't know what she did she
did something to him that really
impressed my dad my dad
probably turkey turkey i didn't know a
turkey neck was that good
yeah like i said he probably deep she
really deep fried it
i mean deep frying stuff makes
everything taste good i don't know what
it
makes everything taste like a donut
except with meat inside yeah
do you want to um get back to talking
about howard you got to go back because
we got to finish this show
even though like we're almost like to
the end okay because we're
at the point now where he's like gone to
crazy town
and uh like i said he's got like the
[ __ ] he looks like a bomb he's got
like the long [ __ ] fingernails and
toenails he doesn't he's never cuts his
hair he's like [ __ ] peeing in bottles
and why not
so yeah so uh
xanada checked [ __ ] population of
[ __ ]
669 that's it right yeah it's a tiny
little [ __ ] town
and and 668 of them are black that one
is my dad
[Laughter]
and [ __ ] it's absolutely unchanged
it's american as apple pie
it's and it's like the 1950s
yeah it's like you know there's twilight
zone episodes where somebody went back
in time yeah
like the fifth exactly that's what it's
like idyllic
stuff black is like that it's black
mayberry
okay that's black mayberry yeah and the
[ __ ] and sergeant who lives across
the street from my dad is the black andy
taylor
okay that's like sheriff taylor exactly
but no i thank them they saved my dad's
life yeah
did you remember he [ __ ] he [ __ ] i
remember had that heart attack on the
[ __ ]
on the [ __ ] stoop of the [ __ ] in his
house and they [ __ ]
called the ambulance and [ __ ] got him
into the ambulance
and my dad kind of like help it helps
raise their
son little kid it takes him hunting and
[ __ ] all the time you know
yeah it's very like it's very small town
so it's very community-based everybody
exactly it's black mayberry it used to
be white mary
mayberry nice black maybe yeah
so all right so the final years of
howard hughes's life like i said when
his health was
deteriorating he was suffering from ocd
he was suffering from all the head
injuries he had
multiple uh drug addictions because of
all of his pain meds
so and he was also super paranoid about
the fbi about the cia watching him all
this other kind of stuff so he kept like
moving around like he would have his
crew like move him to hotels
like he went to the bahamas he went to
nicaragua
he went to england he went to canada he
went to vegas he went to mexico
he was just like going all over the
place he wouldn't stay in one place for
a very long time
now he would um like i said he would
stay at a hotel
and then he would have like his security
detail
like no one could come in to see him he
wouldn't talk to anybody on the phone
i don't know if i mentioned this but he
also had like really bad hearing
problems actually that was um
from when he was a kid like he was
partially deaf
so he um would kind of like
interact prefer to interact with people
over the phone uh than face to face but
even
like you know at this point he wouldn't
even like talk to people on the phone
uh because he had gotten that paranoid
about [ __ ] so
um he so basically hardly anyone
saw him at this stage um
and he wasn't sleeping very much he
wasn't eating very much
like i said he had uh withered to about
94 pounds thereabouts
um so at this stage 1976
uh they decide finally his aides decide
it's like look we have to take him
he was in acapulco at the time and he
said we have to take him back to this
hospital in houston like to get him some
medical treatment
so they put him on a plane they're
flying him back to houston
and he dies on the plane yeah
now after his death there was um
probably not surprisingly there was a
bunch of [ __ ] about
his wills there was a whole thing about
the mormon will
because it was this guy that was like in
the mormon church it was one of the
things he's like hey i found this will
of his
yeah that was at the there was in this
drawer like at the mormon church
that coincidentally 1 16 of his whole
estate which i don't even know how much
that would have been
it was probably a lot goes to me
um but you know and then it was like all
these various other charities and stuff
so there was like a huge like
extended legal battle about that kind of
[ __ ] like about this [ __ ] will
until finally finally they determined
that it was fake
yeah um so i don't even know like i
think most of his money went to
um his medical institute i don't even
you know what i didn't even get into
like all the bribery payments he made to
the nixon
uh you know [ __ ] presidential
election [ __ ] um i didn't get into his
whole thing where
he was like so paranoid about communist
that like he wouldn't let
people like work if if his movies
weren't sufficiently anti-communist he
would like start over
and he would fire people from being like
he was like so paranoid about that kind
of [ __ ]
i didn't get into that there's like
there's so many like avenues that you
could explore
about this he was ocd yeah he was very
rich obviously and that [ __ ] doesn't
[ __ ] mix too well because it's hard
you can do whatever you want people
can't say no to you
and when you're ocd you're gonna come up
with some weird ass [ __ ] and it's gonna
cause a lot of trouble
that's that's really the story and the
sad thing about it was that like a lot
of people i don't
think it doesn't seem a lot of people
that work for him
didn't really seem to take advantage of
him because a lot of people did work for
him for a very long time but
when he kind of went into his final like
downward spiral
he got so paranoid that he fired a bunch
of people that had been with him for
like 20 30 years because he was like
you know paranoid and he thought that
maybe they would you know betray him or
whatever
even though they probably wouldn't have
so it really does seem like he had
people that worked for him for a very
long time
but he kind of [ __ ] them over in the
end
but considering it really doesn't seem
like
a lot of people tried to get too much
out of him like after he died like the
mormons did like that one guy
particularly
um some people came forward later and
said that they were
you know married to him or that you know
there was a book like i said that's on
uh kindle unlimited that said he never
he faked his own death and blah blah
blah there's all this other kind of
stuff i don't
i don't think that's true i didn't even
read that [ __ ] i read like the first
three two or three pages and i was like
okay i don't think so but um well
his mormon security outfit though
undoubtedly in the that one book i read
said that it was pretty much supported
by a lot of the books that they
they pretty much [ __ ]
filtered [ __ ] tens of millions of
dollars off off of his [ __ ]
empire in in his final year not just not
shocked because they knew he was dying
and they also knew he was a [ __ ]
lunatic yeah and
that money was all gonna go to waste so
they were going to use that to help
their church
you know which they thought saw is a
good thing you know
which if you're in a church and you
believe you're right
then you're going to think that's a good
thing you're also going to see it as a
gift from god
because of course you are because it's a
gift from god right of course you are
so i mean he did have his medical
institute which he probably would have
and i
i mean i feel like that got a lot of his
money after he died
because that's still going yeah i
remember there was something about that
it was kind of funny though it was kind
of a circular [ __ ] thing and it was
kind of set up as a tax shelter for
other operations that were running along
none of those
none of those foundations are actually
on the up and up they're all
all of a certain kind of a scam but it
does still exist because
he had really good lawyers and
his main right hand man the darth vader
that i was telling you about
he was with him towards the very end i
think he was one of the ones that got
fired
they were talking about in that final
purge um there was one guy noah dietrich
i think his name was that was with him
for a really long time yes dietrich
that's who you're talking about
yeah dietrich was [ __ ] hired off the
street
hughes this is way back hughes was
famous but this was during the
early part of his empire hughes believed
he was being [ __ ] over by people who
were
lawyers who were better educated in the
law than he was he was probably
right he did not like lawyers didn't
trust him
so he bought a [ __ ] office building
and had that whole goddamn thing
furnished and then just ran all these
personal ads in newspapers all
throughout
la running blind ads about
looking for some want to make a lot of
money are you loyal you know what i mean
and then [ __ ] you know
that kind of that those kind of blind
ads
and had him directed to that [ __ ]
office
and he would sit in there with the
secretary up front
and just all day was [ __ ] talking to
people that would come in and answer
that ad and that's when he met dietrich
and dietrich was a boxer all right
a [ __ ] dude with no higher education
he was just a high school graduate
and he was a boxer and he walks in
[ __ ]
um yeah hughes was impressed with his
physique he's like boy you're
big you know you're in good shape and
started talking to him and
and asked him what he thought about
lawyers and just asked him what he
thought about things and
i probably asked him what he thought
about communists and you know just
talked to him
like that and he ended up saying um
he's saying do you know who i am and
he's like pokey
and he's like no i don't know who you
are and he was like well i'm howard
hughes
and [ __ ] teachers are like no you're
not
[Laughter]
he goes no no no i'm howard hughes and
then he pulled out a newspaper that had
him on it
because i see see i'm howard hughes and
he's like he's like you are howard
hughes and he goes yeah and he goes i
just told you that yeah and he says i
don't trust lawyers and i think
you're an honest guy and because you
don't know anything about any of this
stuff i think i can trust you he's are
you with me are you down you know and
he's like
yeah yeah will you do anything i said
basically it's what he said without
questioning it basically that's the deal
and he goes okay and he goes you know
what i'm going to do for you and then
he's like i'm going to make you one of
the richest most powerful men in the
world and he was like oh
i can write him down thank you you know
and it was absolutely true
because dietrich ended up being one of
the most powerful richest men in the
world
will you stop it pookie oh my goodness
because dietrich himself
dietrich himself ended up [ __ ] being
a multi-multi-millionaire well she he
was with him for
a long time yeah at least 30 years okay
you are
you are making me mad and she knows that
she loves it
she well that's why she does it she
wants to because she's like daddy's
going to come and like
punish she's asking him to go out front
oh she wants to go out front she must go
up front
okay zach said zach just got here he
just got off work
what the [ __ ] zach well he had to work
you know let me put the cat out so we
all got to work
we're going to watch that you can make
me another drink while you're out there
okay
[Laughter]
since we're already here yeah so yeah
the aviator i haven't seen it in many
years i think i saw it in the theater
when it came out
it came out in 2004 right if i'm not
like remembering that wrong
but uh yeah i'm pretty sure i saw that
in the theater and i remember really
liking that very much i mean it's like
kind of
you know it's um you know fantasized
mythologized whitewashed a little bit
but
it's still like a pretty good i remember
that like i haven't seen it a long time
like i said
but i feel like it went a lot into his
relationship with uh
katherine hepburn which actually they
talked about a lot in
the book that i read because she was
apparently
um she was apparently like a really good
friend of his even after their like
romantic relationship ended like she
hung out with him like all the time
and some people have said that she might
have been like the only woman that he
actually loved because like i said i
don't know
he didn't really seem capable of that
kind of thing like he couldn't really
like stick with one woman and even when
he was with her
he was still [ __ ] around with
multiple
other women which pissed her off as it
would piss off pretty much any woman
um but he liked her because she was
unconventional he liked her because she
was
independent she didn't need him um she
was also from a wealthy family she was a
very successful actress she had her own
[ __ ]
she knew what she wanted to do she
didn't need him
and um she was not shy about telling him
to [ __ ] off if he did something that she
didn't like
so i think that he like found that very
compelling
it seems like and like i said earlier it
does really seem like
even though even though for a while he
did seem to be into like really young
starlets who were just coming to
hollywood and they were like 17 18 years
old
uh because they would fall for his
[ __ ] uh because they didn't know any
better
um he did really seem to um
have like a real affinity for women that
would not put up with his crap
and would just like tell him to go [ __ ]
himself
and then like the more they told him to
go [ __ ] himself and he would be like
marry me and they'd be like yeah no
uh i don't really want to and then that
would make that would make him
that would make like him want them more
just because they told him no
you know yeah somebody's asking about he
was faking his death
hughes would disappear all right
all right like i said the book that i
read and this was a long time ago so you
know this
is back in the late 90s that i read this
one this is called the uh
the untold story howard he is the main
source
of information in that book was dietrich
he was the one that [ __ ] contributed
noah dietrich um dietrich knew a lot
about hughes
all right um he knew a lot of private
stuff that was kind of kept
from the public um after he after he
left hughes and hughes died dietrich
went
you know he he he told the story he was
loyal to hughes
he was yeah when when hughes was alive
he didn't [ __ ] spill any beans but he
but after he died he told people
what he uses hughes was about because he
didn't want to one he didn't want to
embarrass howard he liked howard
but he also wanted howard's character to
be kind of edified in history he wanted
people to know who he was what he was
like
yeah so um what was i getting at um
tell me his disappearance yeah what
hughes would do
and this was like when he was in his 40s
and his 50s
he would get stressed out he would sit
around and think about how big his
empire had
gotten and how little control he had
over it and he would drive him [ __ ]
crazy
so he'd start repeating himself and
doing these things that would embarrass
him because he had all these [ __ ]
head injuries he'd start glitching out
so he'd [ __ ] jump in a random car
and just leave and wouldn't would be
gone sometimes for a couple years
yeah wouldn't tell anybody where he was
during that time dietrich's running the
empire
well yeah you had to it's like they just
yeah they were kind of used to it at
that stage because he did that kind of
[ __ ] all the time so they were just like
running [ __ ]
right somebody you would have wanted
someone
i'm gonna tell you dietrich's story i'm
glad you remembered his name she's so
much better with names than me and it
was a long time that i read this book
i told him like three drinks in so
that's good i told her dietrich's story
last time i talked about him i'm telling
again for the main show
dietrich hadn't seen hughes in at least
a year he just vanished
he never got word from he called him
boss
he said boss didn't call him and he knew
that if boss didn't say anything then
boss knew what he was doing and not to
[ __ ] around
just run the empire yeah just do the
[ __ ] just do it
i'm out so he wasn't sure what happened
to boss
sorry lynette says i showed up three
hours late and y'all are still going
strong i love it yeah yeah
yeah we're drunk as [ __ ] you know we're
still going so he didn't know what
happened to boss
out of the [ __ ] blue boss shows up
right where dietrich's working
and walks in and starts [ __ ] giving
out orders like he hadn't been anywhere
and i think he was gone for a year and a
half
maybe two years yeah it was it's almost
like he went to these like weird fugues
yeah where he would like like no time
pass for him
yeah you know what i mean even though
like the world went on without it it
didn't seem like he was like
that much out of it out in the parking
lot was an old [ __ ] jalopy
all right that he pulled up in and he
goes dietrich dietrich dietrich dietrich
and everything he said he said it four
times four
three or four times dietrich dietrich
dietrich
and the car and the car in the car and
the car in the trunk and the trunk and
the trunk
there's you know there's a trunk there's
a box there's a box there's a box i want
you to wrap it i want you to wrap it i
want you to wrap it
i want you to wrap it in number four
butcher paper i want you to wrap it
number one put your paper so it took
forever
to get anything out of hues hughes gives
this law and he says i want you to write
this down write this down write this
down write this down
i can write this down right this round
right this time and it would [ __ ]
drive you up the [ __ ] wall and
dietrich would have to [ __ ] chase
everybody out because boss would be
[ __ ] embarrassed
to be repeating himself so many times
because he seemed to know
yeah he knew yeah but it was like ocd he
had to say it three or four times
to make it official okay yeah well
that's what ocd is right
you have these repeating so he comes
over he's and basically i'm gonna make
it shorter because i don't want to say
it four times
it's just in the picture a little four
like up in the face in the car there's a
box i want you to wrap it number four
butcher paper i want you to use twine i
want you to [ __ ] any draws a diagram
how he wants it wrapped
he says i want i want this taken i want
this taken to a building
off this road he starts drawing a road
out there and i want you to build a
[ __ ] guard house there has to be a
guard in there 24 7. i want [ __ ]
power and i want
a landline for a telephone to go out to
the guard shack
i want the power to go out to another
area where there's going to be an
airfield on the airfield there'll be so
many lights
on the airfield there will be the hangar
will be this big it'd be this big in
this
it'll be for a plane this size blah blah
it goes on and on and on and on
i want you to have a [ __ ] air
conditioning in the guard shack i want
you to take the box and put it in the
guard shack
behind the guard outside the airfield
and that's where i want the box stored
so after they finally get this very
specific very specific
yes so they take the box and they have
all this [ __ ] built and it was built off
of an area in a land where he owned it
they made a [ __ ] like a 10 mile road
out to a guard shack and behind the
guard shack a hacker and then a [ __ ]
airfield they [ __ ] put
landline for the telephone and power to
power all the [ __ ] lights
they put the box inside the
air-conditioned room
and it stays there for about a decade
forgotten
one day dietrich gets a [ __ ] call
from a guy
and it turns out he's the guard and that
guard shack
they had a whole security company
running security to the [ __ ] airfield
for this one box for this one box they
had an airfield and no plane ever landed
on the airfield and like i said earlier
there might be some like pulp fiction
like global yeah [ __ ] in there
yeah or real man if you want to go old
dietrich and his [ __ ]
dietrich had [ __ ] like henchmen that
worked for him too
he's darth vader and these are all the
boba fetts okay
all the boba fett all these boba fetts
yeah right
so sorry i just had a very funny mental
picture
that's my mind went to like a little a
whole bunch i [ __ ] see it
i [ __ ] see everything in star wars
terms
[Laughter]
so i get that i feel you storm trooper
calls them and says i'm over here
[ __ ] i'm the guy guarding the box
remember me i've been out here for 12
years
oh [ __ ] we forgot all about that so
[ __ ] dietrich [ __ ] darth vader's
telling all the [ __ ] star
all the [ __ ] boba fetts remember that
box
yeah they're calling what's up with the
box and he says the air conditioning got
[ __ ] plugged up and
the humidity is dropping out it's
dripping out of the front of the air
conditioner and it's landing on that
damn box it's soaked all the way through
the paper
and like oh [ __ ] if the boss finds out
that water's on that [ __ ] box he's
gonna flip the [ __ ] out we better run
down there so
darth vader and all the boba fetts run
down to the [ __ ] airfield you know
it's [ __ ]
yeah they're [ __ ] all the way on the
other side of california and [ __ ]
and there they see the boxing like and
they're like dude do they steven still
make this kind of butcher paper
how are we gonna wrap this where he will
he
you know won't know that something bad
happened to this
because he's gonna know turns out they
found a butcher paper that was similar
to it though this is he probably won't
know
yeah so they unwrap it and they're going
like should we look in this thing
what's in the box yeah and they were
like thinking the worst they were
wondering
like what's in this box
so it was in a [ __ ] very simple
[ __ ] trunk
they were able to pick the lock or cut
the lock or something i don't remember
what it was
they were able to get through the lock
and opened it up and they were like
bracing themselves to see a dead body
but all they saw was [ __ ] red writer
comic books yeah i would have thought
there's a head in there that's not the
first thing
big stacks of red red writer comic books
and a bunch of douches all wrapped up
with dates [ __ ]
written on them with little tags douches
with tags with dates on them and red
writer comic books
and [ __ ] dietrich looks at all this
[ __ ] and says to the boba fetts
boss has been up to some [ __ ]
what's boss been up to that's the
understatement what's going up to
this is intriguing to me because this
story is true
like comic books okay but the used
douches who did those belong to
and why did he feel the need to save
them all right well in that book it kind
of
kind of plants the seeds of what he's
talking about oh does it does
i'm all ears according to dietrich
back in the 20s and the 30s all right
when he was dating all these young
starlets
howard hughes considered himself to be a
very
cutting edge oriental lick master from
the far east
okay that he was he was engaging
okay in some sexual activities that was
not normal for the time
which is going down on girls oral
pleasure yeah engaging in
right but but according to dietrich's
the woman had douche before he'd do it
well yeah she got to be clean she got
well
you know she had all zach says what
exactly is a real douchebag i'm a gay
guy
back in the old days before they
realized that this was actually very
very bad for you because vaginas are
self-cleaning
like an oven um
they used to tell you that you had to
douche with the stuff you'd like
shoot like this uh you know solution
up your badge like to clean it because
it was supposedly dirty and smelled
yucky or whatever
so you were supposed to do that now like
i said i feel like
that was a thing until what the 80s
because i remember still seeing
commercials from the 80s
but after that they were just like
please stop doing that because it will
give you infections
which it absolutely will yeah um your
vagina cleans itself
uh evolution is taking care of the
problem please knock it off
uh if your vagina smells bad that means
you have an infection
and you should go to a doctor and get
antibiotics other than that
everything should be kosher please don't
shoot anything up there but yeah before
that there was uh there was a big
massing gill was the big brand in the
80s right so
i remember seeing commercials so so what
what lord dietrich tells us
is that there was evidence of howard
hughes licking [ __ ]
and for some reason well hey he's he's
good for him
for some reason he has dated it and
edified it
into these [ __ ] nicely portable
packages that he can put
simplified and storage right along with
his red rider comic books
and you have to put that [ __ ] outside
the airfield in air conditioning
with guards guarding it okay because
he's got a
who knows like who might need to see
that at some point yeah
he's keeping that [ __ ] for possibility
and if i remember
all that [ __ ] all that [ __ ] that he had
built out there
was all just eventually forgotten and
abandoned anyway
you know what i mean as the [ __ ] 70s
and 80s as the 70s rolled around
and howard died all that [ __ ] he never
went back to that [ __ ]
zach said okay but what's the bag part
for i think put water if you catch that
it just kind of yeah to catch the water
coming out of the faucet you hang it out
of the faucet
and then yeah you put it underneath the
[ __ ] faucet of a [ __ ]
shower head and turn the shower head on
and it fills inside the bag
and then it goes down the thing and it's
just so you can spray in there that's
all it was it was like an
enema but for your veg yeah that's all
it was essentially
but like i said um that was a big thing
and like i said i still remember seeing
commercials for like mass and guild
issues like up until the 80s
but after that they were just like hey
please don't do that because yeah you
said that already
yeah that's it's it's not good for you
yeah you're not really supposed to do it
but i um one thing this is really funny
but i remember seeing
[ __ ] in like cosmo from like the 60s and
70s
yeah where they were telling you to
douche with coca-cola
yeah they probably did that was supposed
to be like a birth control
kind of like it's supposed to like kill
sperm or some [ __ ] yeah they would say
some [ __ ] like that i'm just like i
don't think that would work
just okay coca-cola will do a lot of
things but it might it might work
the thing is though it'll probably give
you a bad infection that's what i'm
saying all that sugar
you can't that's what i mean you can't
add yeast to sugar you can't
look you can't even use mr bubble
mr bubble got in trouble in the seven
step rhyme didn't mean four or two
but in the 70s and 80s because that's
[ __ ] you pour in your bathtub and it's
supposed to like make big bubbles and
it's like making a bubble bath
but it gives you infections
yeast infection urinary tract infection
you can't put like
all this [ __ ] up in your vag and like
it gets infected and it's not fun it's
all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] in there to
kill
not fun okay
tom's getting uncomfortable with the
talk of female anatomy i don't care
i'm a girl i've had to put up with this
[ __ ] my entire life so i'm not bothered
at all
but i guess always boys don't like it
no no i'm just saying all right so
what else is left ken says in the
dillinger movie with pamela sue martin
she douched with pop and soda yeah that
was a thing
yeah it was supposed to be like a birth
control i thought or it was supposed to
like clean out your [ __ ] they didn't
that would have been sugar cane yeah
sugar all right
still not good though no no i don't
think so it would give you a bad yeast
infection oh
because uh that's just giving that's
just giving yeast food yeah
nobody wants that sugar and yeast to
just make bread
you'll [ __ ] yourself up i imagine they
probably got away with it on a limited
basis
but that's not something you could
regularly get well like i said just like
everything else
you could you can do it every now and
then and it won't do anything but if you
do
[ __ ] regularly you're rolling the dice
each time yeah i mean like i was telling
him
the other day like i'm not gonna say who
this was but somebody of my acquaintance
of my
uh personal acquaintance was really
worried about
germs like in their mouth and
so they would constantly uh use
mouthwash
and they use so much mouthwash that they
killed all the good bacteria in their
mouth and they got thrush
yeah because you need some bacteria in
your body
to combat well there's good bacteria the
bet yeah there's good ones and i
and i feel like people like we have to
kill all the bacteria always
no we evolve with that that's really
really bad if you do that please don't
yeah
you evolve with certain bacterias that
kind of symbiotes with you
yeah [ __ ] defense help protect
millions of years of evolution
lucky you didn't lose your teeth doing
that because [ __ ] there's a lot of
bacteria that protect your teeth too
it's kind of like why it's good to use
um you know like
anti-bacterial soap like sometimes but
if you use it too much yeah
i mean you're kind of working against
yourself
you know what i'm saying like to an
extent that's good but you can't do too
much of it or you're killing like the
good bacteria that like is
like you said like a symbiont with you
yeah so you know
all right so i think we're probably
pretty much done with the show huh we
probably are oh
my god almost four hours long how did we
do that i know that i know
[ __ ] ridiculous um let me see
uh you're drunker than i am yay yeah if
anybody wants to contribute to the show
you can send us a [ __ ] super chat if
you want a shirt
if you send us send me a 20 super chat i
can send you a shirt
yeah we got a couple guys we got two to
got a bunch of different kind of shots
tomorrow and mail on um monday
yeah got [ __ ] snake pliskin i got
[ __ ] uh
13 o'clock shirts got whalen industry
whaling got wayne yutani
uh i don't know what else i have right
now we're gonna come up with some new
stuff too here soon
so uh if you guys want to send a super
chat now's the time if not
you can like share and subscribe we got
55 on there right now
michael says and jenny is still sober
i'm not but at least i'm appearing sober
yeah
which is appearing silver yeah good for
me you're not
yeah uh many people have requested a
pookie shirt
uh yeah we can come up with something
like that how let's
i feel like the pookie shirt has to be
like really something
that's on you you got to come up with
something i know i got to come up with
something it's really hard for me to
like it's not that hard for me to like
design
stuff for other people but when i'm
designing stuff for we can do it
for our show it like takes me forever we
can take a picture of her like we
somehow translate that maybe in dot
matrix
yeah i feel like because i feel like it
has to be a photograph of her
because i don't want to just like use
clip art of a cat that kind of looks
like her because it's not her
you know what i'm saying that's that's
the issue that i'm having okay but we
need to get a good enough photo of her
that it's because it has to have her
little stumpy tail in it because that's
one of her
you know identifying features yeah
and um you know so i don't know we'll
we'll see how it goes if i do a cobra
kai shirt it's going to be just cobra
kai i'm not going to mix it with plisket
when is the new season of cobra kai
because i noticed that netflix
uh added the first two seasons which
we've already seen because we had like
youtube premium
yeah um i'm guessing they're doing the
third season of cobra kai
yeah but i don't know when it's coming
out however i did notice
you guys if you guys like the haunting
of hill house haunting a bly manor
which is uh directed by mike flanagan
and
based on uh the turn of the screw by
henry james
october 9th i just saw the trailer for
that [ __ ] yesterday
i'm so excited it looks really good okay
let's go ahead and shut it down it's
time for us to go
all right remember if you like the show
like share subscribe on all your social
media it really does help us a lot
uh in the algorithms if you like if you
comment if you do all that kind of stuff
um and remember if you'd like to
financially support show you can go to
our patreon page patreon.com
13 o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog 13 o'clock podcast.wordpress.com
and there is a button in the sidebar to
a paypal account which goes right to
me so uh you know helps out with all the
expenses of the show various bills yeah
things if i do a pookie shirt it's gonna
be pookie with pookie's head on
the body of the child from mandalorian
that's probably what i do or it could be
pookie with her stumpy tail but with
baby yoda ears
yeah i don't know i i can't think of
like because i feel like i don't really
want to do
pookie is her own person so i don't know
if i want to like mash her up with
another
character because she's kind of her own
character yeah you know what i was
saying
so he said if tom made a drink and
called it the hughes what would it be
thank you elsa thank you very much elsa
what are you guys doing for the long
weekend
probably the same [ __ ] we always do
drink and like watch
old star trek yes on the 18th sophie's
gonna be here and she's gonna do a
couple shows with us so you guys have
fun with that
also this tuesday at 8 p.m
eastern time i'm gonna be on uh
conspiranormal we're doing a whole like
mega show
like all the people that are gonna be on
the strange realities khan
are gonna be on the show so i don't know
how much time i'm gonna have to talk but
you know
so we're doing a show tuesday at 8 p.m
so
check that out so what would a huge be a
huge i'm thinking a huge would be some
kind of a [ __ ]
it's got to be like some kind of 20s
drink like a gin ricky or something
i'm thinking it has to have kind of like
a butterscotch flavor to it
oh i like that some kind of [ __ ]
a whiskey type i don't know i was
thinking it would taste like
butterscotch
or something some i don't know it's hard
to say i have to think about it
i like butterscotch for some reason
every time maybe because i'm thinking of
[ __ ]
just 20 like the great gatsby type of
[ __ ] for some reason i always associate
gin with the 1920s
i guess because of bathtub gin because
of like probably i think it would be
butterscotch butterscotch um
liqueur vodka
and a shot of half a half in it on the
rocks
ilsa says the hughes is whiskey with
urine and jar
yeah not okay all right
all right now you've [ __ ] done it
you've done it because you have to
understand you called it a jar and
that's not what it was
it was well milk bottles he was pissing
in milk bottles
okay so do we really need to be that
pedantic yeah
because because yes the hughes drink
okay would be butterscotch liqueur
vodka on the rocks with a shot of
[ __ ] half and half in it
inside one of those little [ __ ] glass
milk bottles
that comes from [ __ ] with a little
bit of pee in it yeah a little bitty
glass milk bottle like from [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh starbucks you know little
starbucks [ __ ]
coffees iced coffees like that that's
what i was picturing
yeah that was that's kind of like the
milk bottles that when i lived in the uk
that was like
when the milkman would come that was
kind of like they were a little bit
bigger than that but that was like the
milk bottle that they would leave on the
doorstep like with the foil top yeah
yeah that's kind of what they were
michael says i've pissed in beer bottles
before
i think most dudes have somebody said a
slippery nipple is a slippery nip of
what i just described
it's butterscotch it's butterscotch i
can't remember what else is in it but it
might be a rum drink
okay um but it's like a butterscotch
kind of flavor
that's like a butter rum lifesaver
that's probably i'm thinking that's
probably something hughes would have
liked
that sounds like his jam doesn't yeah or
if not
something kind of orange and cream so
that might be like
drambuie vodka
and half and half on the rocks or some
kind of banana nut
yeah cocktail yeah which sounds totally
gross i'm not like
i'm not super into bananas you guys yeah
i don't
like a real banana oh yeah i can take it
or leave it but the artificial banana
flavor
yeah no thank you i really do not like
artificial banana flavor
of any type all right this is ian we can
shut this [ __ ] down i'm gonna go
he's getting he's getting impatient
all right we're late he left all right
we're leaving
just sit there all right all night we'll
see you guys we're gonna laugh stream
again tomorrow it'll either be like a
new movie or probably be a sidetrack
show
um so we'll see you guys tomorrow thanks
everybody for stopping by
bye